David Boder: [In English] Italy, September the 1st at the Castle Tradate, between Milano and Como, at a Home for displaced Jews who expect from here eventually to be transferred, one way or the other, to Palestine. The interviewee is Mr. Isaac Wolf, thirty years old, here with his wife and a child. He lives here in the camp. He is exercising some administrative duties and in part, for that reason seems to have a room for himself with his family.
David Boder: [In German] Also, Herr Wolf, wollen Sie uns zuerst sagen, hm, nochmal wie heißen Sie und wie alt sind Sie?
Isaac Wolf: Wolf Isaac, alt dreißig (30) Jahre.
David Boder: Sie sind dreißig (30) Jahre alt, ja und was tun Sie hier—was nennen Sie diesen Platz? Hachsharah?
Isaac Wolf: Hachsharah.
David Boder: Was tun Sie hier in Hachsharah?
Isaac Wolf: Wir arbeiten und lernen sich verschiedene Arbeiten.
David Boder: Und haben Sie irgend ein Amt hier?
Isaac Wolf: Nein [unverständlich]...
David Boder: Sie selbst sind was?
Isaac Wolf: Ich bin selbst bin ein Arbeiter von Mascu [eigentlich unverständlich; klingt wie Mascu].
David Boder: Was ist das?
Isaac Wolf: Das ist ein Mitglied von der Gesellschaft von den Führern...von die Leute von Hachsharah.
David Boder: Aha, Sie sind im Kommittee?
Isaac Wolf: Im Kommittee, ja.
David Boder: Aha...und was haben Sie zu tun speziell?
Isaac Wolf: Ich versorge...dass Lebensmittel soll sein...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . und Lebensmittel für die Leute und sauber das alles.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Hygiene und alles was nötig...
David Boder: Also Sie sind sozusagen...sind sie gewählt von die Menschen?
Isaac Wolf: Von die...gewählt von...
David Boder: Gewählt von die Menschen...in demokratischer Weise?
Isaac Wolf: Vollständig demokratisch.
David Boder: Bei Männern und Frauen?
Isaac Wolf: Bei Männern und Frauen und alles.
David Boder: Und die Jungen auch?
Isaac Wolf: Ja, alles.
David Boder: Alle haben gewählt?
Isaac Wolf: Ja, alle hundert Prozent.
David Boder: Ihr kleines Kind hat nicht gewählt?
Isaac Wolf: Nein...kleines Kind nicht [lacht] das ist selbstverständlich!
David Boder: Wie alt ist es? Ist es ein Junge oder ein Mädel?
Isaac Wolf: Wer? Meines?
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Es ist ein Mädel.
David Boder: Und wie alt ist sie?
Isaac Wolf: Vier (4) Wochen! [lacht]
David Boder: Sie ist vier (4) Wochen alt? [lacht]
Isaac Wolf: Ja! [lacht]
David Boder: Oh! [lacht etwas] Nun also, sagen Sie mir dies, Herr Wolf, [spricht nun in Jiddisch] sag mir, wo seid Ihr gewesen, wenn der Krieg hat angefangen und was hat denn passiert?
Isaac Wolf: Es ist gewesen im neun und dreißiger (39) Jahr, die erste Zeit von dem Krieg...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Ich bin gewesen in Lemberg und dann hat angefangen der Krieg und ich bin eingerückt in die polnische Armee.
Isaac Wolf: War ich in der polnischen Armee und dann habe ich gekämpft unter Lemberg auch...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und dann bin ich [unverständlich] geworden.
David Boder: Verwundet?
Isaac Wolf: Verwundet geworden, ja.
David Boder: Wo sind Sie verwundet geworden?
Isaac Wolf: Bei Lemberg?
David Boder: Ja, ich meine, wo an Ihrem Körper sind Sie verwundet...
Isaac Wolf: In der Hand.
David Boder: Sie sind verwundet geworden in der Hand, nun?
Isaac Wolf: Ja.
David Boder: Und?
Isaac Wolf: Und dann bin ich im Spital gelegen. Und dann sind einmarschiert die russische Armee.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und dann bin ich schon gewesen in Russland, da heißt, in Lemberg, und dann war schon die russische Armee in Lemberg.
Isaac Wolf: Und dann bin ich gelegen im Spital und bin gesund geworden. Da war ich...war ich unter der russischen Regierung.
David Boder: Ja. Das war noch...da war noch kein Krieg.
Isaac Wolf: In neun und dreißig (39).
David Boder: Ja, Russland und Deutschland...[beide sprechen]
Isaac Wolf: Wenn Polen und Deutschland...
David Boder: . . . aber nicht Russland mit Deutschland.
Isaac Wolf: Nein, das war so, dass, hm,...
David Boder: Nicht offiziell.
Isaac Wolf: Nicht offiziell. Es war so...wenn die Russen haben...die Deutschen haben auf Lemberg geschossen...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . da haben die Russen...die Russen in Lemberg Antwort gegeben mit...auch...es war so ein Missverständnis...
Isaac Wolf: . . . zwischen den Armeen. Da war auch ein gewisser...ein paar Stunden war auch so ein...
David Boder: Aber offiziell waren die Russen und Deutschen nicht im Krieg.
Isaac Wolf: Nicht.
David Boder: Und so, nun, Sie sind gelegen im Hospital, was ist dann passiert?
Isaac Wolf: Und ich bin gelegen...so sechs (6) Wochen war ich im Spital, dann bin ich zu Hause gekommen.
David Boder: Ja. Wen haben Sie zu Hause gehabt? Wer waren Ihr Vater, Ihre Mutter? Was war die Familie?
Isaac Wolf: Ich war zu Hause...eine Mutter habe ich gehabt, einen Vater, Schwestern und Bruder...
David Boder: Wie viele Schwestern?
Isaac Wolf: Ich habe gehabt zwei (2) Schwestern.
David Boder: Ältere oder jünger?
Isaac Wolf: Eine...zwei (2) Jüngere.
David Boder: Aha.
Isaac Wolf: Und einen Bruder, einen älteren Bruder, einen Bruder hab ich gehabt...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Er hat gewohnt in Rade...[Rest unverständlich; beide sprechen].
David Boder: Ja und einen Vater und eine Mutter haben Sie gehabt?
Isaac Wolf: Ja.
David Boder: Nun, wie Sie sind nach Hause gekommen,...
David Boder: . . . was haben Sie dann getan?
Isaac Wolf: Dann bin ich, hm, eingetreten, in die Arbeit. Die Russen haben nicht erlaubt so herum gehen ohne Arbeit.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Weil, wenn man hat nicht gearbeitet, haben sie gefragt, von wo leben Sie?
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Und da hat jeder Mensch gemusst zu gehen arbeiten.
David Boder: Aha, ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und dann bin ich angetreten zur Arbeit, Da hab gearbeitet auf der Eisenbahn. Da habe ich gelernt...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . und ich habe gearbeitet als Bahnmaschinist.
David Boder: Also Sie haben sich gelernt als Bahnmaschinist? Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Nun und dann habe ich gearbeitet die ganze Zeit. Es war so, wenn an einem Tage ich hab nicht gearbeitet, nicht ich...nur Andere, dann haben die Russen gefragt: „Warum ist er nicht gekommen jeden Tag zur Arbeit?“
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Wenn sie gewusst haben eine gewisse Ursache, warum er ist nicht gekommen zum Arbeiten.
David Boder: Haben sie gezahlt für die Arbeit?
Isaac Wolf: Bei der Arbeit hat man gezahlt.
David Boder: Ja. Hat man können leben davon?
Isaac Wolf: Nur so wie in Russland, wie bei der Verordnung...wenn einer hat verdient, hm, hundert fünfzig (150) Rubel, hat er auch gekonnt auch leben um hundert (100), hm,...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . Rubel, weil es war so, dass wir haben gegessen in einer Küche. Und in der Küche hat es gekostet sechzig (60) Rubel ein Mittag und fünfzig (50) Rubel und hundert (100) Rubel und so...
David Boder: Hundert fünfzig (150) Rubel am Tag?
Isaac Wolf: Am Tag.
David Boder: Ja, ja und nun?
Isaac Wolf: Nun und so...Nein! Hundert fünfzig (150) Rubel ein Monat.
David Boder: Nun das heißt nur ‚Kobiete’ [unverständlich; beide sprechen].
Isaac Wolf: Dreißig Kobieten...dreißig für [unverständlich]
David Boder: Oh ja!
Isaac Wolf: Ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Nun man hat gekonnt auskommen so...zu sammeln...sparen Geld eigentlich...
David Boder: Konnte niemand?
Isaac Wolf: Konnte niemand in Russland, aber leben konnte man eigentlich gut für dieses Geld, von diesem Geld was man hat bekommen.
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Und dann habe ich gearbeitet als Maschinist schon dann habe ich verdient tausend (1000), tausend fünf hundert (1500) Rubel. Das war schon sehr viel. Das haben gekonnt im ganzen Monat zwei Familien daraus leben.
David Boder: Nun, Sie haben gearbeitet als Maschinist auf der Eisenbahn? Richtig?
Isaac Wolf: Eisenbahn und ich bin gefahren...
David Boder: Mit der Parovoz?
Isaac Wolf: Mit der Parovoz.
David Boder: Lokomotive?
Isaac Wolf: Lokomotive, ja.
David Boder: Nun weiter.
Isaac Wolf: Und...
David Boder: Wie lange hat man sich gelernt für Maschinist?
Isaac Wolf: In Russland war ein Kurs, der hat gedauert sechs (6) Monate und acht (8) Monate und ein Jahr. Nach die Monaten hat man beendet den Kurs. Und die Zeit vom Kurs haben sie bekommen, genau so wie sie arbeiten...weniger etwas, aber sie haben—sie sind ganz mit diesem Geld ausgekommen.
David Boder: Nun weiter.
Isaac Wolf: Und dann habe ich gearbeitet bis zu der Zeit von dem Krieg.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und in der Zeit von dem Krieg, wenn die deutschen Flieger haben schon bombardiert Lemberg, hab ich auch...
David Boder: Wenn der Krieg angefangen von die Russen und die Deutschen.
Isaac Wolf: Mit die Russen und die Deutschen, ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Und da hab ich auch noch gearbeitet auf der Eisenbahn.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und bis...die zwei (2) Tage bis die Deutschen da hereingekommen sind...
Isaac Wolf: . . . habe ich gearbeitet an der Eisenbahn unter den Bomben, unter dem alles. Jeder hat gemusst gehen zu der Arbeit, er hat nicht dürfen verlassen diese Arbeit.
David Boder: Nun.
Isaac Wolf: Und dann wenn die Deutschen schon waren hinter Lemberg, dann hab ich nicht können gehen mit meine Eltern .
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Bis...
David Boder: Nicht können gehen mit ihren Eltern
Isaac Wolf: Nein, ich kann nicht weg schmeißen die Arbeit und ich hab nicht können gehen und ich hab nicht gesehen meine Eltern bis zum heutigen Tag. Und ich war...dann bin ich weg gelaufen mit der russischen Armee weiter und ich bin gelaufen bis Woloczyst. Und dort bei Kiev...auf der anderen Seite...sind wir umringelt worden von die Deutschen.
David Boder: Auf der anderen Seite?
Isaac Wolf: Auf der anderen Seite...schon an der russischen „border“ schon.
David Boder: Ja?
Isaac Wolf: Das war Popoloczysk and Woloczysk.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Das war schon bei der Ukraine.
Isaac Wolf: Und dann sind wir rein getreten, da haben die Russen uns gefangen, umzingelt den Wald und...
David Boder: Die Deutschen.
Isaac Wolf: Die Deutschen. Und wir waren...wir sind eingetreten als Partisanen, alleine [unverständlich]...weil wir haben gewusst,was sie machen mit die Juden, denn wir haben gelesen das Buch Unser...„Mein Kampf“.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Dann haben wir gewusst, was es ist...was bedeutet die Judenfrage. Und wir haben gewusst, gutwillig zum Tod wollen wir nicht gehen. Solang wir können retten das Leben, werden wir sich retten.
David Boder: Nun ja, Sie sind gegangen mit den Partisanen? Warum...
Isaac Wolf: Nun ja...
David Boder: . . . sind Sie nicht gegangen mit der regulären Armee?
Isaac Wolf: Man hat nicht gewollt annehmen dann noch, hm, uns, weil die haben nicht gewusst wer wir sind. Weil die haben genommen in der russischen Armee...von die neun und dreißiger (39) Jahre bis zu die ein und vierziger (41) Jahre, bis zur Zeit von dem Krieg, hat man genommen die Jüngeren.
David Boder: In Polen, ja?
Isaac Wolf: Von die Polen. Kein Unterschied—Juden, Polen, Ukrainer, alle. Nun dann haben wir gewusst unter den Zeiten von Krieg hat man nicht gewollt uns rein nehmen...ohne, das heißt, ich soll da sagen—ohne [unverständlich]...heißt es auf Russisch.
David Boder: Ohne Kommission.
Isaac Wolf: Ja und dann...
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Isaac Wolf: Ja. Dann hat man genommen und man hat gesagt, wir sollen gehen weiter nach Russland. Dort wird man uns nehmen unter eine Kommission. Und da haben wir selbst gesehen, dass es schrecklich schlecht ist und wir haben gar nichts gehabt in der Hand um zu retten das Leben. Und so sind wir in den Wald. Dann hat man erschossen viel dieser Leute, die Soldaten, die Russischen. Dann haben wir genommen von die Tote die Waffen, das Gewehr und Automaten und alles was das war und dann hab ich gewohnt acht (8) Tage auf die Bäume.
David Boder: Auf die Bäume?
Isaac Wolf: Auf die Bäume hab ich gewohnt. Mit diese Riemen, die ich habe bis heutzutage als ein Andenken. Da hab ich mich zu gebindet mit einem Riemen an den Fuß...
David Boder: Ein Riemen?
Isaac Wolf: Ein Riemen, ja. Zugehalten bei dem Fuß und ich dem Anderen hab ich mich mit dem ganzen Körper, damit ich soll nicht herunter fallen. Und so habe ich gegessen. In der Tasche habe ich gehabt vielleicht ein halbes ( ½ ) Kilo Brot.
David Boder: Aha.
Isaac Wolf: Und dann mit diesem halben ( ½ ) Kilo rot...und dann war auch noch ein Kollege, der hat vielleicht zwei (2) Kilo trocken Brot gehabt. Und mit diesen...haben wir von einem Baum zum Anderen geworfen. Und mit diesem haben wir gelebt ein paar Tage.
David Boder: Warum haben Sie müssen sein in einem Baum?
Isaac Wolf: Was?
Isaac Wolf: Warum? Weil die Deutschen sind herum gegangen und haben geschrien: „Da sind...Juden und Russen sind da...hier.“
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Wir haben Angst gehabt, weil sie da unten herum gegangen sind und haben gesucht uns im Wald. Dann haben wir gesehen, der Tod ist schon vor unseren beide Augen. Sie verstehen es?
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Wir haben schon nichts mehr zu verlieren. Wir haben gesagt: Wenn wir es so machen, vielleicht können wir uns retten das Leben.“
Isaac Wolf: Und dann sind wir so gegangen über das Wasser und so...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: So über Wälder und dann haben wir getroffen eine russischen Patrolle.
David Boder: Ja?
Isaac Wolf: Dann haben wir gesagt, dass wir selbst gehen und verteidigen uns als Partisanen.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Gutwillig, weil wir wollen nicht gehen zu die Deutschen, weil wir wissen, was er macht mit die Juden.
Isaac Wolf: Dass wenn er fand einen Juden, dann schneidet er Händ, Füss, Ohren, schneidet er aus, dass die...er hat selbst nicht gewusst was er soll machen. Dieser Barbar war so schrecklich gegen die Juden, dass wir haben gesagt gutwillig zum Tod wollen wir nicht gehen. Und dann sind wir gegangen bis die Russen haben uns getroffen. Haben uns noch zusammen genommen mit russische Leute, mit Juden und wir sind gegangen wieder in den Wald. Wir haben noch viele Deutsche...haben wir tot geschlagen auch, weil haben mit uns angefangen. Wir haben gehalten die Pistole so in der Hand, dass sie sie nicht bemerken. Und wenn Einer ist auf uns zugekommen und hat gesagt, wir sollen die Hände halten hinauf, haben wir die Hände gehalten so und gleichzeitig haben wir ihn tot geschlagen. Und wir sind dann weiter gegangen. Es waren so etliche mit uns—acht (8) Leute waren es.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und dann haben wir...fünfzehn Deutsche haben wir tot geschlagen. Damals...bevor sie konnten uns tot schlagen, uns suchen, da haben wir sie gleich tot geschlagen und dann wir sind weiter gegangen. Dann kam eine russische Patrolle und die Russischen haben angehalten und gefragt, wer wir sind. Und da haben wir gezeigt die Papiere und dass wir russische Eisenbahnarbeiter sind. Und wir sind Juden. Da haben sie uns gelassen reden und sie haben gar nichts gesagt und geglaubt uns. Und dann haben sie gefragt, wohin wir gehen. Und wir haben gesagt, uns ist das egal. Wir wollen gehen in die russische Armee oder die Partisanen, weil die...wir wollen nicht in den Tod gehen.
David Boder: Aha.
Isaac Wolf: Und da hat man uns genommen in die russische Armee. Und dann bin ich gegangen in die russische Armee, ich war in der russischen Armee und bei Stalingrad habe ich gekämpft.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Und ich hab Abzeichen auch noch von der russischen Armee. Und ich habe gekämpft bis zum letzten Tag von dem Krieg.
David Boder: Alright.
Isaac Wolf: War drei (3) Mal...[unverständlich].
David Boder: Sie meinen verwundet?
Isaac Wolf: Verwundet.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Ja.
David Boder: Auf welchem, welchem, hm,...Körperteil waren Sie verwundet?
Isaac Wolf: Die Hand wieder das nächste Mal und dann am Fuß.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Das war ich und ich habe gekämpft. Ich habe gesagt, dass ich gut willig...zum Tod sollte ich nicht gehen.
Isaac Wolf: Für mich selbst...diese Rache habe ich genommen, weil sie haben tot geschlagen meine Eltern, meine...
David Boder: Haben Sie das gewusst?
Isaac Wolf: Ich habe es gewusst, weil ich habe gehört davon, man hat gesehen, man hat gemacht mit unsere Eltern und gleichzeitig man hat befreit Lemberg...
David Boder: Oh, nachher?
Isaac Wolf: Da hab ich gefragt und von Rawa Russka auch, von dort...von meine Freunde. Da hat man mir geantwortet, die Deutschen haben sie mit einem schrecklichen Tod...haben sie totgeschlagen. Man hat genommen und verbrennt im Krematorium. Man hat die Brüste abgeschnitten, die jüdische Frauen und Mädeln. Sie haben so schrecklich gemacht. Da habe ich gesagt, wenn sie haben das gemacht mit meine Eltern, dann hab ich gar nicht was zu verlieren. Da nehme ich dann diese Rache für meine Eltern. Hier kann ich sie totschlagen...kann ich totschlagen, dann können sie mit mir machen was sie wollen. Dann bin ich gegangen schon, wie so gesagt, wie ein Blinder.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Dann bin ich gegangen zur Front, dann habe ich gekämpft. Und die russische Armee hat anerkennt, dass ich gekämpft hab gut,...da habe ich bekommen wieder Abzeichnungen: so: Krasnaya Zwiezda—Roter Stern. Sie verstehen?
David Boder: Ja, ich verstehe.
Isaac Wolf: Den roten Stern und ich hab bekommen eine Medaille für Stalingrad.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Guter Kämpfer, das heißt auf russisch Boyeviye Zaslugi.
Isaac Wolf: Und ich hab bekommen die Oboronyi Kavkas.
David Boder: Was?
Isaac Wolf: Kavkas ja? Und die Oboronyi...Pobiedyi and Germanyi—das hab ich schon bekommen zum Ende der Zeit auch. Ich habe gekämpft gut und ich habe gesehen, dass...jeden Moment ist neben mir gestanden der Körper Vater, Mutter und Schwestern und Bruder—ich hab noch dieses Bild bis zum heutigen Tage. Das war so mit mir, bei jedem Mensch, bei jedem Jud, dass das Blut hat aufgewallt , ich weiß, dass ich hab gar nichts zu verlieren. Dann bin ich gegangen und ich hab sehr viel Rache genommen auch an diese Deutschen auch.
David Boder: Oh.
Isaac Wolf: Und dann am Ende von dem Kriege, da hat man gesagt, dass man kann fahren nach Lemberg. Ich bin gefahren...in der Zeit von dem Krieg bin ich gefahren nach Lemberg.
David Boder: Wo sind Sie gewesen? Wo waren Sie?
Isaac Wolf: Bin ich gewesen überall...Rumänien, Ungarn, Österreich, die Tschechei, Tschechoslowakei. Sie wissen ja, wo das ist?
David Boder: Ja, ich weiß wo das ist.
Isaac Wolf: Und ich war in Ungarn und wieder war ich in der Karpaten-Ukraine. Dort habe ich gekämpft. Zum Teil waren das russische Ukrainer die Partisanen. Die russischen Ukrainer waren dort, diese „Banderovtzi“. Sie haben geholfen den Deutschen. Weil die Ukrainer waren noch viel schlimmer, wie die Deutschen. Das war so ein Volk, wenn sie haben genommen die jüdische Gemeinde in Lemberg, haben sie sie aufgehangen in die Gassen und haben gesagt: „Das sind Juden. Die haben geholfen mit die Juden, die müssen wir jetzt tot schlagen.“ Man hat, wie sie lebend waren, abgeschnitten die Augen, aufgeschnitten die Ohren, die Nase, die haben sie ausgebrennt innen mit heiße...hm, wie Pferde. Haben sie bemerkt, an die Pferde macht man Nummern, and die Militär Pferde.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Das haben sie gemacht. Sie haben raus geschnitten ein Stück Fleisch von die Füss. Jeder Jud hat gemusst tragen ein, eine, eine diese...
David Boder: Einen Stern.
Isaac Wolf: Einen Stern. Und dann, wenn ich bin gewesen in Lemberg, ich gesehen, wie ich angekommen. Und fremde Leute waren dort bei uns...in dieser Wohnung, wo wir haben gewohnt . Und ich bin stehen geblieben und meine Herz war so...wie Steine, ich hab nicht gekonnt sprechen und ich bin niedergefallen,...so...ich war gänzlich ohne Macht. Man hat mich gerettet, dann bin ich wieder gegangen. Ich bin herumgegangen, wohin soll ich gehen suchen? Ich war dann auf dem Friedhof...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . auf dem [unverständlich].
Isaac Wolf: Dort hab ich getroffen ein alter Mensch, der hat mir gesagt: „Da liegt Deine Mutter. Was man, die hat man tot geschlagen und da habe ich sie begraben.“ Und dann...gleich bin ich zurück gefahren zu der russischen Armee und in der russischen Armee bin ich wieder gegangen kämpfen und in der letzten Zeit, wo man schon hat gehört, der Krieg ist zu Ende, war ich in Budapest . Und dann hat man gesagt, dass ich kann fahren zu Hause. Hab ich gesehen, wenn ich komm zu Hause, wen werde ich dort treffen? Nicht kein Vater, niemand und es kann auch sein, dass ich Selbstmord begehe. Es war so: während der sechs (6) Jahre hab ich so viel Gesundheit verloren...und jetzt kommen nach Hause und niemand treffen, wie kann ich zu Hause da bleiben? Nicht niemand. Man hat gesehen die jüdischen Häuser. Sie haben schon Bomben da herein geschmeissen, so dass sie überhaupt nicht existieren. Und wir haben auch gesehen das Blut...
David Boder: Das war in Lemberg?
Isaac Wolf: In Lemberg. Das Blut war noch in der Gasse nicht vertrocknet...von den Juden. Und dort war noch ein Brenner [unverständlich], wo man hat verbrennt die Menschen, da hab ich noch gesehen wie die Erde hat sich noch gehoben.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: In der Zeit von dem Krieg...da hat man frische Menschen da herein gelegt.
David Boder: Nun warten Sie mal, erzählen Sie mir das noch einmal.
Isaac Wolf: Ja.
David Boder: Wann haben Sie gesehen, dass die Erde sich geheben hat?
Isaac Wolf: Sowie Lemberg hat man befreit.
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Sie verstehen. Und dann war es so,...wenn die Menschen waren...die Ukrainer...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . wenn sie haben getroffen einen Juden auf der Gasse, dann haben sie ihn tot geschlagen.
David Boder: Ja?
Isaac Wolf: Sie verstehen?
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Man hat ihn nicht genau gekonnt tot schlagen.
Isaac Wolf: Die waren noch lebendig...und dann haben sie so ausgehoben ein Grab und haben ihn herein gelegt und so hat man ihm mit Erd verschüttet. Und wenn wir waren in der Nähe, ja,...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . sie verstehen, haben wir gefangen ein Dorf, eine Stadt, wir sind herein gekommen, Sie verstehen, und die Ukrainer sind weg gelaufen und die Juden waren noch...das Blut war noch warm von die Menschen, die sie haben tot geschlagen. Weil sie haben gesagt, es waren Juden und die haben sich erhalten bei Christen. Sie haben gegeben Gold, sie haben gegeben ihr ganzes Vermögen, dass die Christen soll sie behalten. Er hat das Geld zu genommen und hat gesagt: „Ich werde ihnen verhalten“. Verhalten, sie verstehen? Und auf der anderen Seite hat er dem Kollegen, dem Ukrainer gesagt. Die Ukrainer haben viel mehr Juden selbst tot geschlagen, wie die Deutschen.
David Boder: Ja, aber, was sagen Sie, dass die Gräber sich bewegt haben?
Isaac Wolf: Ich selbst...
David Boder: Haben Sie das selbst gesehen?
Isaac Wolf: Ich selbst...mit meine Augen, weil...
David Boder: Wie lange zurück waren die Menschen begraben?
Isaac Wolf: Mit einige Stunden zuvor, ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Und dann, hm, war ein rumänischer Doktor, der hat gearbeitet im Arbeitslager, sie verstehen? Und er war junger Doktor. Den haben sie auch behalten bei sich. Und dann ist dazu gekommen eine...
David Boder: Wer hat behalten bei sich? Die Ukrainer?
Isaac Wolf: Die Ukrainer haben gehalten, dann haben sie...gewusst er ist ein Jude, dann haben sie ihn genommen mit den Deutschen zusammen, Sie verstehen? Sie haben gesagt, er soll sich selbst ausgraben einen Graben und soll sich herein legen, Sie verstehen? Mit Erde zugedeckt [unverständlich]. Und gleichzeitig hat gemacht einen Angriff die russische Armee und man hat eben gedenkt, dass die Erde hebt sich...
David Boder: Ah hm.
Isaac Wolf: . . . und man hat ausgegraben und da war noch diese, wie man sagt, zwanzig (20) Prozent am Leben. Und dann hat man ihn Einspritzen gemacht, da hat der Sanitäter, der hat ihm Einspritzen gemacht, Kampfer hat man gegeben und so hat man gerettet sein Leben.
David Boder: Sagen Sie, wie tief muss man Einen begaben, damit man sehen kann, dass sich die Erde bewegt?
Isaac Wolf: Ah, so, es vielleicht ein halber ( ½ ) Meter oder so...
David Boder: Ein halber ( ½ )...
Isaac Wolf: . . . etwas. Sie haben so...nicht sehr tief begraben. Er hat ja gesagt, er soll es sich selbst ausgraben, Sie verstehen?
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Er war bedeckt mit Steinen zuvor und so haben sie genau...sie haben nicht tot gemacht nicht hundert (100) Prozent tot sein. Verstehen Sie?
David Boder: Ja, ich verstehe.
Isaac Wolf: Sie haben genommen so, dass er soll sich rächen, die Rache. Wenn sie getroffen haben eine Frau, da hat man abgeschnitten die Brüste. Und man hat gemacht einen russischen Stern oder ein jüdisches Abzeichen. Und dann man hat getroffen ein junges Mädel, hat er mit ihm Verhältnisse gehabt.
David Boder: Wer? Die Ukrainer?
Isaac Wolf: Die Ukrainer, die Deutschen. Dann sagt er: „Da hast Du ein Andenken, dass die Deutschen und die Ukrainer haben Dich gehabt.“
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Und dann es war bei Verhältnissen so, dass er...ein Mann hat gehabt eine Frau, Dann war für ihn, dann hat er genug, dann hat er genommen Rache. Dann hat er einen Stecken aufgebrochen, Sie verstehen? Und den Stecken hat er ihr herein gesteckt. Dann sagt er: Hier...das ist,...Du sollst ein Andenken haben, dass die Deutschen mit Dir ein Verhältnis gehabt haben.“ So...so...
David Boder: Zu dem Mann?
Isaac Wolf: Zu der Frau. So haben sie gemacht, Sie verstehen.
David Boder: Sagen Sie das nochmal. Sie haben nicht mit der Frau...
Isaac Wolf: . . . ein Körper Verhältnis gehabt mit der Frau...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . aber nur einen Stecken. Sie verstehen?
Isaac Wolf: . . . hinein gesteckt, so haben sie ein junges Mädel behandelt, das nie ein Verhältnis gehabt habt mit niemandem.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: So brutalisch sind sie vor gegangen mit jüdische Mädel.
David Boder: Haben sie das gesehen oder...
Isaac Wolf: Mit meine Augen hab ich getroffen ein Mädel...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . ein junges Mädel...was man hat das mit ihr gemacht. Aber wissen Sie, wieso das macht die russischen Partisanen, denn die sind immer herein gegangen in die Städten...
David Boder: Ja, in die Städte.
Isaac Wolf: In die Städte oder in die Dörfer und sie waren zivil angezogen und gleichzeitig haben sie gehabt der Verbindung zu der russischen Armee....
David Boder: Ja?
Isaac Wolf: mit den russischen Patrollen. Und wenn es war ein kleines [unverständlich] eine gewisse russische haben sie gehabt, hm, so...brutalisch vorgegangen . Sie haben gesehen, dass es mehr Leute und weniger [unverständlich] oder russische Patrolle, da haben sie das Telefon gegeben oder gleichzeitig ein Signal gegeben, dass die Russen sind herein gekommen und haben sie gleichzeitig gefangen lassen. Ich war in einem russischen Dorf es heißt Bessarabia. Kamina heißt das.
David Boder: Was heißt das, ‚sie haben gefangen’?
Isaac Wolf: Die Ukrainer gleichzeitig bei diesem Attentat was sie ausgeführt haben gegen die Juden.
David Boder: Ja?
Isaac Wolf: Sie versehen?
David Boder: Ich verstehe!
Isaac Wolf: Gleichzeitig war ich...[unverständlich; beide sprechen]
David Boder: Ich verstehe, aber man muss sehr vorsichtig sein, was man sagt, denn es muss alles die Wahrheit sein und nicht was Einer hat erzählt.
Isaac Wolf: Nein, ich habe selbst mit meine Augen gesehen, ich war sechs (6) Jahre in der Krieg.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und ich habe selbst bis zum heutigen Tage, bis zum Ende des Krieges...
Isaac Wolf: . . . hab ich mit gemacht und ich habe gesehen sehr viel.
David Boder: Ja, nun? Weiter!
Isaac Wolf: Und gleichzeitig bin ich gewesen in...Bessarabia...es war da...
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: . . . haben wir befreit...Kaminka heißt das.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Ein...das ist ein großes Dorf oder eine Kleinstadt. Ein Kurort war das.
David Boder: Ja?
Isaac Wolf: . . . wir wurden befreit. Rumänische Offiziere haben wir getroffen, das war bei Bystrica.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Hat man...
David Boder: Das ist ein Fluss?
Isaac Wolf: Ja.
David Boder: Weiter.
Isaac Wolf: Da haben wir getroffen...eine jüdische Frau haben wir getroffen mit einem jungen Mädel, eine Mutter mit einer Tochter. Das Mädel war alt sechzehn (16) Jahre.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Und ein rumänischer Offizier hat mit ihr gewohnt. Mit der Mutter Einer und ein Kollege hat gewohnt mit dem Mädel...
David Boder: Gelebt?
Isaac Wolf: Gelebt ja und in einem Zimmer.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Sie verstehen? Und wie wir sind herein gekommen, haben wir nicht gewusst und wir haben gefragt, ob es gibt noch hier Juden. Weil ich hab nicht geglaubt, dass nachdem was die Deutschen haben gemacht, dass so was möglich ist, dass ein Jude bleibt am Leben, Sie verstehen?
Isaac Wolf: Dann haben sie gesagt, dass sie...sie haben gefangen diese rumänischen Offiziere, die Rumänen waren noch mit den Deutschen zusammen.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und die waren noch besoffen ein bisserl in dem Zimmer und gleichzeitig sind wir als Patrolle herein gekommen und haben die Rumänen gefangen.
David Boder: Und die Frauen waren dort?
Isaac Wolf: Nicht zusammen mit in diesem Zimmer. Dann haben wir die Pistoletten und die Automatischen...aufgestellt. Da haben die Rumäner gesagt: „Fragen Sie die [unverständlich –polnisches Wort]
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Ich sage: „Sind sie ein Jud?“ Sagt sie: „ja“. Weil die Rumänischen kann doch nicht jüdisch sprechen.
Isaac Wolf: So habe ich zu ihr gesagt:“Seid ihr Juden?“ Sagt sei: „Ja.“ „Was macht ihr da?“ Sie sagt: „ Überleben, wir haben gewollt retten das Leben. Und die Rumäner haben gesagt: „Wenn ihr wollt retten das Leben, dann musst Du mit mir wohnen.“ Sie war wunderbar schön.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und das Mädel war schon schwanger von diesem rumänischen Offizier.
Isaac Wolf: Und gleichzeitig die Mutter auch. Wann ich habe das gehört, habe ich angefangen die Tränen mir von die Augen gekommen, weil ich habe schon lange Zeit keine Juden nicht gesehen. Und hat sie mir erzählt das. Und ich habe gleichzeitig gebeten unseren Arzt, dass er soll Hilfe geben, es sollte nicht verspätet sein für das junge Mädel.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und gleichzeitig haben in das Zimmer...[unverständlich; spricht sehr schnell]. Die Offiziere haben wir mit genommen und wir haben gefragt, warum sie haben das gemacht. Und man hat das runter gegeben zu Gericht...
Isaac Wolf: Und diese Frau hab ich—hab ich selbst—gesetzt in das Zimmer, ich hab sie Lebensmittel gegeben und dann hab ich dem Mädel auch etwas angezogen...
David Boder: Und was haben Sei den Doktor gebeten, er soll für das Mädel tun? Ein Abort...
Isaac Wolf: Selbstverständlich—ein sechzehn (16) jähriges Kind...ein Mädel was hat von einem Rumänen, ein...
David Boder: Ein Kind hat.
Isaac Wolf: Ja. Und die Mutter gleichzeitig auch. Da habe ich gefragt die Mutter, da hat sie angefangen zu weinen. Sie ist mir auf die Füße gefallen und hat gedankt, dass wir gerettet haben ihr Leben. Sie hat gesagt, niemand wird sie nicht vergessen, was ich habe für sie gemacht. Und sie hat wissen wollen, den Namen geben, meinen, dass sie denken kann, was ich für sie gemacht. Und ich habe sie über gelassen dort und wir sind weiter gegangen zu der Front.
David Boder: Sie glauben nicht, dass die Frau freiwillig gelebt hat mit ihm?
Isaac Wolf: Sie haben mir erzählt, dass er hat sie gezwungen dazu. Dann hat er gesagt, er wird sie herein [unverständlich]...herein schmeißen in den Bystrica, er hat schon Tausend Juden herein geschmissen. Sie verstehen?
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Nicht weit von dieser Wohnung, wo sie haben gewohnt—vielleicht hundert (100) Meter, war diese...hm,...
David Boder: Der Fluss.
Isaac Wolf: . . . der Fluss.
David Boder: Ja. Nun, hm, wie lange waren Sie in Stalingrad?
Isaac Wolf: In Stalingrad war ich vier ein halb (4 ½ ) Monat.
David Boder: . . . [unverständlich]...in welchem Monat war es? Bis Stalingrad ist frei geworden?
Isaac Wolf: Bis Stalingrad ist frei geworden—ich bin die ganze Zeit gewesen in Stalingrad.
David Boder: Wollen Sie uns etwas erzählen von die letzten zehn Tage in Stalingrad, oder die letzten zwei (2) Wochen?
Isaac Wolf: Ja.
David Boder: Bitte
Isaac Wolf: Ja, das kann ich Ihnen genau erzählen.
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Die letzte Zeit in Stalingrad hat die russische Armee konzentriert all die ganzen Kräfte auf Stalingrad...
David Boder: Die Deutschen?
Isaac Wolf: Die russische Arme, weil die haben gesagt: „Stalingrad—das ist die Lebensfrage von Russland.“
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: „Wenn Stalingrad verloren, dann ist Russland verloren“. Die deutsche Armee hat einen sehr starken Angriff gemacht und hat sehr viel vorbereitet. Gleichzeitig hat Russland auch vorbereitet. Wenn wir waren bei Stalingrad haben wir gehört [unverständlich—polnisches Wort klingt wie ‚Baruska’] hm, über—wie heißt das—Japan...
David Boder: Japan.
Isaac Wolf: . . . auch Japan seht bereit anzugreifen Russland...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . und die Türkei auch; so hat man den Bericht gegeben in der Zeitung. Dann haben wir gewusst, dass jeder Russischer und jeder Jud hat gar nichts zu verlieren, weil der Tod ist vor der Tür.
Isaac Wolf: Und wenn man ist lang im Krieg, Sie verstehen, dann macht kein Angriff von die Flieger oder gar nichts, das ist dann sowie eine Musik. Und dann hat man konzentriert die ganze Armee dort und man hat einen Tag gestellt viele Tausend an einen Kilometer und viele tausend von die russische Katyusha...
David Boder: Was ist eine Katyusha?
Isaac Wolf: Katyusha, das ist eine...eine, wie soll ich sagen...ein Geschütz auf einem Auto, ja, Sie verstehen??
David Boder: Ja. Eine Kanone?
Isaac Wolf: Eine Kanone, aber das hat sehr viele...das hat zwei und zwanzig (22)...und die Kleine hat für zwölf (12) oder vier und zwanzig (24), Sie verstehen? Für Schüsse...doch eins nach dem anderen.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . für eins nach dem anderen, verstehen Sie?
Isaac Wolf: Das ist sehr...sehr...das hat sehr viel geholfen.
David Boder:
Isaac Wolf: Und die Deutschen haben sehr viel Angst bekommen von diese, hm, Katyusha. Wenn sie haben gehört das Katyusha fangt an, sie...haben sie gesagt: „Oh, jetzt geht schon...Ivan kommt schon!“ Sie verstehen, sie haben sehr Angst gehabt. Und dann haben angefangen die russischen Flieger, alles konzentriert auf sie. Und in einigen Tagen haben sie angefangen Angriff zu machen. Und dort hat man umringelt die russische Armee.
David Boder: Die Deutsche?
Isaac Wolf: Die deutsche Armee.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Die Russen haben die Deutschen. Und dann haben wir gewohnt in Gräber—Sie verstehen—man hat gemacht gegen die deutschen Panzer...
Isaac Wolf: . . . hat man gemacht Riesengrosse und dort haben wir gewohnt. Die Kälte war so schrecklich, das es ist sehr schwer gewesen. Ein Feuer machen hat man nicht gekonnt, denn die deutschen Flieger sind herum geflogen und haben patrolliert. Sie verstehen?
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und haben angeschaut. Vielleicht ist dort einen Attacke. Die Bomben waren so, dass eine nach der anderen ist gefallen und viele Leute sind niedergefallen und sind geblieben. Ich habe gehabt einen Kollegen, was ist...neben meiner Hand ist er geblieben. Und ich hab mich zugedeckt mit seinem Körper...und er ist tot geblieben und ich bin...ich habe noch einen Anzug, wo Löcher ich hab von diese, hm, Abfall von diese Bomben.
David Boder: Von diesen Splittern.
Isaac Wolf: Splittern von der Bombe. Ja, und dann ich hab gehabt ein Buch. Es ist drauf geschmissen auf mein Buch und mir ist gar nichts passiert. Und...
David Boder: Was für ein Buch war es?
Isaac Wolf: Was? Eine Buch...ein jiddisches Buch halt.
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Und dann bin ich bei Stalingrad, es hat angefangen. Wieder hat man gesehen, dass die Deutschen haben bemerkt diesen Punkt. Dann hat man uns wieder gerückt auf ein halbes Kilometer. Und dort sind wir wieder gekommen. Der Frost war ungeheuer.
David Boder: Welchen Punkt haben die Deutschen bemerkt?
Isaac Wolf: Das ist neben [unverständlich], das war dort bei die Gräber, da hat man das verdeckt und dort haben wir gewohnt. Heizen hat man nicht gekonnt. Das Wasser war schrecklich gefroren und es war ein Wind, ein großer. Und dann hat man gemacht einen Angriff und man hat die Deutschen umgeringelt und dann hat es angefangen zu kämpfen in Stalingrad in den Strassen. Ich war in Stalingrad, hm, am Anfang des Krieges. Es war eine sehr schöne Stadt. Und in der Zeit von dem Krieg ist Stalingrad so ruiniert, dass man kann nicht finden eine Häuser. Sehr wenig Häuser, die kann man selber zählen. Und es waren Straßenkämpfe—die Straßenkämpfe waren wunder...waren schrecklich. Es kann, es kann...ich bin nicht im Stand, dass ein Mensch das erzählen kann, diese schrecklichen Kämpfe was war. Ich bin herein gekommen in einen Bunker, Sie wissen, was das ist, eine Schützengraben...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Wir haben das selbst ausgegraben. Wir haben getroffen dort Zivilleute und Deutsche. Wir sind herein gesprungen, weil wir haben nicht gekonnt Granate rein schmeißen, weil es wegen die Deutsche...die deutsche [unverständlich; spricht sehr schnell] war, wir sind herein gesprungen dort hin und da haben die Deutschen die Zivilleute tot geschlagen. Es war so schrecklich, bis man hat Stalingrad, hm, hm, genommen.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Und wann man hat Stalingrad genommen, da waren sehr viel deutsche Gefangene, SS Männer. Und so haben wir gekämpft sehr gut. Und dann sind wir nach Stalingrad weiter gegangen. Und dann hat man uns gemacht [unverständlich], da heißt man hat uns in andere Kompanien gegeben, Sie verstehen?
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und dann haben wir...dann war ich wieder in Corsa Szewczenko.
David Boder: Was ist das?
Isaac Wolf: Das ist auch bei...Corsa Szewczenko, da ist bei, hm, Czerkassy...Smielo...dort weiter herauf.
David Boder: Nun, sagen Sei, was hat man in Stalingrad gegessen,wenn Stalingrad belagert war?
Isaac Wolf: Essen, was soll ich Ihnen sagen, man hat nichts gehabt zu essen und nichts zu trinken, gar nichts. Man hat gegeben ein kleines Stückerl Brot, weil man hat nicht gekonnt dazu zu kommen. Wir waren umzingelt, so. Sie verstehen?
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Lebensmittel zu kriegen, war sehr schrecklich. Ich kann Ihnen sagen so viel, weil; die russischen Leute sollen haben so viel [unverständlich] und die russische Armee; sind sie nicht im Stand mit diese Lebensmittel zu existieren. Mit einem Stückerl trockenem Brot, mit ein bisserl Eiswasser oder Kaltwasser, ohne Zucker. Zum Rauchen haben wir nichts gehabt. Da haben wir genommen Blätter, die man hat gefunden. Was für Blätter, das soll nicht sein. Und Einer hat geraucht und der andere hat aufgemacht den Mund und hat den Rauch herein gehabt. So haben wir...es war [unverständlich] schrecklich und man war nicht im Stand...jeder Mensch hat gehabt, ich selber hab gehabt, die Füß, die waren so geschwollen. Und der...der hat mir gesagt, ein Arzt, das hab ich bekommen von einem abschwächendem Herz.
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Sie verstehen?
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Wir haben bekommen gegen Fungi, weil der Fungi, da war so reingegangen in den Fuß. Wie man auf Russland sagt: „porok serdsa“.
David Boder: Porok serdsa, ja.
Isaac Wolf: Man hat mir gesagt, sie verstehen. Das habe ich gehabt und noch viele Leute hatten das. Diese Leute was waren in Stalingrad, da kann man sagen, es gibt ein Prozent (1%) was gesund ist, weil drei (3) Monate oder sechs (6) Monate wir sind gelegen nass und gepresst und...
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: . . . bei Frost und Schnee und allem.
David Boder: Hm. Wie geht es Ihnen, wie fühlen Sie jetzt?
Isaac Wolf: Und jetzt bin ich auch sehr abgeschwächt. Wenn, wenn es kommt ein Regen, dann kann ich Ihnen das ein paar Tage zuvor sagen. Und jetzt auch noch die Hand, ich habe noch einen pressierte Hand.
David Boder: Eine verwundete Hand?
Isaac Wolf: Eine verwundete Hand—ich kann sie nicht halten.
David Boder: Aha. Was heißt, Sie können nicht halten?
Isaac Wolf: Ich kann nicht ausstrecken.
David Boder: Welche Hand? Die Andere...Sie können sie nicht ausstrecken, ja
Isaac Wolf: Und wir sind gegangen [unverständlich] und dann war ich in Wien auch.
David Boder: Ja?
Isaac Wolf: [unverständlich] Und bei Wien habe ich gearbeitet bei der Eisen...bei Schiff Abteilung, weil ich habe schon nicht mehr gekonnt kämpfen, weil ich bin plessiert gewesen. Aber da war ich schon in der Ingenieur Abteilung.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Ich hab gearbeitet in der Ingenieur Abteilung und dann bin ich schon gewesen in Ungarn und in Ungarn bin ich gewesen bis zur letzten Zeit vom Krieg.
David Boder: Aha und dann haben die Russen sie demobilisiert?
Isaac Wolf: Sie haben gesagt ja...wir sind demobilisiert und sie haben gesagt, ich soll nach Hause gehen nach Lemberg. Da hab ich gesagt, ich habe nichts zu suchen in Lemberg, weil...ich kann nicht kommen nach Lemberg, weil Lemberg ist ein jüdischer Friedhof.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Sie verstehen?
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und ich habe gesagt: „ich will nicht fahren.“ Und dann habe ich, dann muss ich nehmen den historischen Stecken. Wie man sagt: „der ewige Wanderer“ und ich muss wandern. Ich kann nicht nach Hause kommen zu diesem Haus nach sechs (6) Jahren und nicht treffen meine Eltern und niemand zu Hause da. Da müsste ich Selbstmord begehen. Und da bin ich gegangen und habe angefangen wieder zu wandern.
David Boder: Wohin sind Sie dann gegangen?
Isaac Wolf: Dann bin ich gegangen nach...von Ungarn bin ich gegangen nach Österreich. In Österreich war ich...da waren sehr Viele was ich getroffen hab von Konzentrationslagern. Diese Menschen was man hat befreit...von die Englischen und Amerikanische...und da haben die Juden angefangen zu wandern. Der hat gehört, dass er Niemanden zu Hause hat. „Für was will ich gehen nach Hause?“ hat er gesagt. Und ist gelaufen...gehen. Und so Viele sind gestorben auch auf der Gasse, weil sie haben nichts gehabt zu essen. Dann haben sie gegründet von der jüdischen Gemeinde,—dank der amerikanischen Hilfe, die man hat gegeben der, der...den Juden von die Lager. Da hat man angefangen zu machen Küchen. Und hat angefangen Schuhe zu geben und Anzüge und Spitäler und das Rote Kreuz. Und dann hat man angefangen denen ein bisserl zu helfen, den Juden. Und man hat gemacht Lager—jüdische Lager.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Die jüdischen Lager, wo die amerikanische Armee war, waren nicht schlecht.
David Boder: Waren was?
Isaac Wolf: Waren nicht schlecht, Sie verstehen, waren ganz gut! Weil die Amerikaner, wenn sie haben das gesehen, wie schrecklich...denn die Deutsche haben die Juden abgeschnitten die Haare, von die jüdischen Mädel...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und sie haben gesehen, die schauen aus sehr schlecht, waren solche Menschen, die haben Geld gegeben und sie haben Medizinen gegeben und man hat gemacht ein Lager und man hat die Juden in das Lager gegeben. Ich selbst war in Österreich im Lager, wo die Englischen sind gewesen. War sehr schlecht. Warum? Sie haben nicht so viel mit gelebt gehabt mit die Juden.
Isaac Wolf: Verstehen Sie?
David Boder: Kein Mitgefühl?
Isaac Wolf: Mitgefühl, sehr wenig. Es waren solche...es war vielleicht einer ein Jude. Wir haben gewusst, er ist ein Jude, aber er hat es wollen nicht heraus sagen, dass er ist ein Jud.
David Boder: Ein Engländer?
Isaac Wolf: Ja, ein Englischer...ein Jud. Er hat uns zur Arbeit genommen, in den Wald sollen wir gehen und Holz schneiden. Da haben wir gesagt, wir kommen jetzt von der Armee, von den Lagern, wir sind noch krank. Das geht ihn nichts an. Wir gehen zu der Arbeit...wir sind gegangen zu der Arbeit. Dann haben wir gesehen, dass der Tod ist uns vor den Augen auch. Und dann haben wir angefangen zu wandern. Dann haben wir gewollt gehen nach Italien. Haben uns die Engländer gefangen...
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: . . . und man hat uns so, so wie die Deutschen, die SS mit Automaten hat man uns geführt zurück. Dann sind wir eingesperrt, wir waren eingesperrt. Das war bei Villach.
Isaac Wolf: Wir waren eingesperrt und dort sind wir gesessen und sie haben gewollt uns abgeben nach...dem Konzentration...dort war ein Lager von, hm, Juden, hm, was haben genommen die Engländer...mit österreichischer Bewachung...wir wurden gehalten für Engländer.
David Boder: Hm.,
Isaac Wolf: . . . und das war...
David Boder: Was meinen Sie mit österreichischer Bewachung?
Isaac Wolf: Österreichische Polizei.
David Boder: Hat bewacht die Juden?
Isaac Wolf: Hat bewacht die Jüdischen zusammen mit die Engländer.
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Und gleichzeitig haben genommen...geben die Engländer die Ukrainer, weil sie sind geflohen von Polen, weil sie haben nicht gewollt fahren nach Hause, weil sie haben gewusst, dass die Polnischen werden sie tot schlagen...und...mit die Russische, weil sie waren Verbrecher, weil sie haben viele Juden tot geschlagen und viele Russische. Die Ukrainer...
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: . . . diese Ukrainer haben diese Ukrainer diese Wache über die Juden—auch in Judenburg...
David Boder: Wo war das?
Isaac Wolf: Das war...das war Judenburg in Österreich—das war englische Zone, das war in der englischen...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . Abteilung. Die Engländer haben genommen die Ukrainer als Polizeimänner, als Polizeiwache. Und sie haben die Juden bewacht. Und dabei haben sie die Juden nicht essen lassen. Wenn ein Jude ist gekommen und hat gesagt, ich habe Hunger, ich will noch einmal, haben sie ihn weg getrieben. Wenn er will noch ein Stückerl Brot...weil sie haben das unter dem Mantel der Engländer, die ihnen gegeben haben eine Erlaubnis als Polizei—haben sie da auch genommen Rache. Jetzt haben sie genommen Steine und haben sie geschmissen auf die Juden.
David Boder: Wer?
Isaac Wolf: Die Ukrainer...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . wenn sie sind gestanden als Polizei, als Wache.
Isaac Wolf: Sie verstehen. Und dann hat man die genommen als Chauffeure die Ukrainer und die Juden hat man nicht gelassen [unverständlich]. Die Engländer und dann ist gekommen...wir waren in Trofaiach...
David Boder: Wo?
Isaac Wolf: Das war ein jüdisches Lager auch. So wir...
David Boder: Wie hat es geheißen.
Isaac Wolf: Trofaiach.
David Boder: Trofaiach
Isaac Wolf: Ja, das ist nicht weit von...
David Boder: Trofaiach- ist das Jiddisch?
Isaac Wolf: Nein, dort ist ein deutsches...so heißt es Trofaiach. Das ist ein Dorf...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . von Judenburg nicht weit.
Isaac Wolf: Dort war...wir hatten einen Direktor, ein Jude, der Direktor of UNRRA.
David Boder: Auch ein Jude?
Isaac Wolf: Ein Amerikaner.
David Boder: Und?
Isaac Wolf: Er war schon...er hat mitgefühlt mit die Juden, er hat gemacht für die Juden sehr viel. Was hat er gemacht? Er hat gelernt jüdische Chauffeure sein.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Er hat gelernt die Juden...ganz angestrengt hat er sich. Er hat gelernt Juden angezogen. Er hat gemacht ein Schüler jüdische. Er hat gemacht ein Kino für die Juden im Lager. Und er hat sich bemüht und wir haben sofort erkennt, dass er nicht ein Engländer, ein englischer Jüd ist, aber ein Amerikanischer, Sie verstehen?
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und er hat hundert Prozent (100 %) mit geholfen die Juden, dass ich nicht im Stand bin, es zu erzählen. Weil wir sind heraus gekommen von Judenberg nach Trofaiach...
David Boder: Ja?
Isaac Wolf: . . . das war im...das war im, hm, hm, November, Dezember im fünf und vierziger (45) Jahr. Er hat so viel gemacht, er hat angezogen, er hat gefahren nach Graz. Er hat gebracht selbst...wenn die Juden sind angekommen, hat er selbst mit der Maschine, als Chauffeur hat er die Juden gebracht, weil er hat nicht gewollt, dass sie in der Kälte sind. Und er hat viele Doktoren gebracht, Medizinen. Man hat die kranken Juden gerettet. Die Juden haben viel mit geholfen.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool number 100 taken at Tradate, between Milano and Como in Italy on September 1, 1946. The interviewee is Mr. Isaac Wolf in the Hachsharah in Tradate and we will continue with him on Spool number 101. An Illinois Institute of Technology Wire Recording.
David Boder: September 1, 1946, Italy, camp for cooperative in Castello Tradate, between Milano and Como. Spool number 101. Mr. Isaac Wolf, interviewee, is continuing.
David Boder: [In German] Also, Herr Wolf, was sagten Sie über Trofaiach? Wer war dort in, hm,...
Isaac Wolf: Trofaiach.
David Boder: . . . Trofaiach, wie schreiben Sie Trofaiach? Ein Moment. T...
Isaac Wolf: O
David Boder: J, F...
Isaac Wolf: I...
David Boder: I...
Isaac Wolf: A...C H.
David Boder: Trofaiach, ja, ist das ein deutsches...
Isaac Wolf: Nein, das ist ein Österreichisches.
David Boder: Eine österreichische Stadt. Also gehen Sie weiter.
Isaac Wolf: In Trofaiach haben wir auch etwas gesehen...Das war sehr schrecklich...
David Boder: Die Engländer waren in Trofaiach?
Isaac Wolf: Ja, ja, ja, ja.
David Boder: Nun und so?
Isaac Wolf: Und sie haben nicht erlaubt ein Jud soll heraus kommen vom Lager ohne Erlaubnis von den Engländern. Hat nicht erlaubt fahren, hat nicht erlaubt gehen. So haben wir gesagt: „Warum sollen wir hier sitzen, nach der Zeit von dem Krieg sind wir wieder in einem Konzentrationslager.“ Los wir gehen nach Italien. Hat man uns gefangen.
David Boder: Was heißt „Los wir gehen nach Italien’/
Isaac Wolf: Wir...wir selbst sind gegangen nach Italien...
David Boder: Wie Viele sind Sie gegangen?
Isaac Wolf: Hundert dreißig (130) Mann waren wir zusammen.
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Und wir sind gegangen...[beide sprechen]
David Boder: Was für eine Organisation waren diese hundert dreißig (130) Mann? War das schon ein Kibbuz?
Isaac Wolf: Ein Kibbuz.
David Boder: Ein Kibbuz.
Isaac Wolf: Ja.
David Boder: Wer hat den Kibbuz organisiert?
Isaac Wolf: Ich selbst.
David Boder: Haben Sie...waren Sie ein Zionist bevor?
Isaac Wolf: Ja. Ich habe zusammen genommen mein [unverständlich], was ich habe gekannt, die waren zusammen mit mir in der Armee und so und ich habe...den Kibbuz Dror Haonim.
David Boder: Wie hat es geheißen?
Isaac Wolf: Kibbuz Dror Haonim.
David Boder: Dror Haonim?
Isaac Wolf: Ja.
David Boder: Was heißt das?
Isaac Wolf: Das ist Dror...das ist ein „Dror“ was früher in Polen. Und Habonim, das war eine ungarische Organisation, wir haben die Organisation zusammen genommen, Sie verstehen? Sie haben sich vereinigt, die Jugend in einer demokratischen...
David Boder: Organisation.
Isaac Wolf: Organisation.
David Boder: Ein Moment.
Isaac Wolf: Ja.
David Boder: Hm, schreiben Sie mir das auf in Jiddisch.
Isaac Wolf: Oh, ich kann es Ihnen aufschreiben in Deutsch auch.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Dror, oh.
David Boder: Wer hat diesen Namen gegeben Dror Habonim?
Isaac Wolf: Das haben sich vereinigt diese...Jugendlichen. So wie es war...sagen wir...ein Kibbuz, hm, Hashomer, ein Kibbuz, sagen wir...
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: So verschiedene Kibbuz...so Verschiedene. So haben es genannt Kibbuz Dror Habonim.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und wir haben angefangen. Wir haben gesehen, wir haben ja gar nichts zu verlieren,...nach sechs (6) Jahren Krieg sind wir wieder herein in ein Konzentrationslager,...war mit Draht unringelt, Sie verstehen?
Isaac Wolf: Und die Österreicher sollen stehen mit Wache;...so wie im Konzentrationslager! Wir haben nicht gewollt das zu erlauben und wir sind gegangen nach Italien. Da hat man uns gefangen...die Englischen. Man hat uns mit Automaten zurück geführt.
David Boder: Wie viele Menschen, alle hundert (100) Mann?
Isaac Wolf: Alle hundert fünfzig (15). Es waren noch Juden, die sind gegangen, so hat man uns zurück geführt—drei hundert (300) Mann.
David Boder: Wie weit von Trofaiach war das?
Isaac Wolf: Das war von Trofaiach hundert achtzig (180) Kilometer. Das war von Villach fünfzehn (15) Kilometer.
David Boder: So weit weg hat man Sie dorten getroffen...
Isaac Wolf: Ja.
David Boder: . . . und zurück gebracht?
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Die Österreicher haben gesagt, dass die Juden gehen. Da haben die Engländer zurück geführt mit Automaten und...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . und man hat es gemacht so...wie so ein Verbrecher.
Isaac Wolf: Und man hat nicht gelassen heraus uns...
David Boder: Zu Fuß?
Isaac Wolf: Zu Fuß...
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Nein, man hat herein geführt zu Fuß zur Bahn, das was nicht weit. Und man hat uns zur Bahn geführt. Und von der Bahn sind wir heraus gesprungen und wir sind gegangen wieder. Dann haben die Engländer...
David Boder: Wie viele sind heraus gesprungen?
Isaac Wolf: Alle. Ich habe alle bis zum Letzten...von der Bahn habe ich heraus geschmissen alle Menschen.
David Boder: Wie langsam ist der Zug gegangen?
Isaac Wolf: Der Zug ist langsam gegangen. Der Maschinist hat langsam...
David Boder: Der Maschinist ist langsam gefahren?
Isaac Wolf: Es war nicht weit von Villach von der Station.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Es war unser Glück, dass die Gleiche war vergeben.
Isaac Wolf: Und er hat langsam gefahren bis er herein gefahren ist nach Villach.
David Boder: Ja, ja.
Isaac Wolf: Weil in Villach hat schon gestanden die englische Polizei. Da haben wir schon nicht mehr gekonnt...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . und die Österreicher, es war gut, es war bei Villach...
David Boder: Ja, aber Sie waren doch unter englischer Bewachung?
Isaac Wolf: Die englische Wache war in den andren Wagonen, Sie verstehen?
David Boder: Hm. Sie...
Isaac Wolf: Und wir haben aufgemacht die Fenster und die Tür und wir sind heraus gegangen. Weil unser Wagon war nicht der englische Wagon, die waren im dritten (3.) und vierten (4.) Wagon.
David Boder: Ja,
Isaac Wolf: Weil es waren drei Wagon, Sie verstehen?
David Boder: Sprechen Sie langsamer.
Isaac Wolf: Ein bisserl Juden hat man gefangen, ein bisserl Juden.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Die haben sie eingesperrt, sie waren ein Monat, zwei Monat. Und wir sind gefahren. Wir haben nicht wieder gewollt nach, hm,...weil wir gewusst haben, man führt uns in ein Konzentrationslager.
David Boder: Ja?
Isaac Wolf: Sie verstehen? Dort waren schon viel Juden dort...die waren schon dort eingesperrt. Dann sind wir weg gelaufen zu Fuß nach Koblenz.
David Boder: Aha.
Isaac Wolf: Dort war ein Lager, da hat sich kürzlich gegründet. Dort war ein jüdischer Lagerführer, Mr. Katz,...
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: . . . ein Amerikaner. Er war ein Vater, ein Vater kann man sagen, für diese Juden dort.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und er hat uns Mut gegeben und für die Juden...was er halt gekonnt hat. Wir sind gekommen, wenn es schneit.
David Boder: Was war der erste Name von Mr. Katz?
Isaac Wolf: Hm, das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
David Boder: Aber...das war in Koblenz?
Isaac Wolf: In Koblenz, das war...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Das war im...im...im...wann war das...so im März war das.
Isaac Wolf: Und er hat gemacht, was er hat gekonnt machen, hat er gemacht für uns. Er hat Schuhe gegeben, hat uns angezogen.
David Boder: War das die UNRRA?
Isaac Wolf: Das war schon immer...das war von der UNRRA, ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und er hat immer...er ist auf uns zugekommen und hat uns mit Autos, wenn man gesagt hat, da Juden sind gekommen...war keine Chauffeure. Und da hat er genommen und selbst sich herein gesetzt in dir Maschine und er hat die Juden transportiert in das Lager. Hat alle registriert. Man hat gegeben sofort Essen und die Kranken ins Spital gegeben. Und er hat gemacht hundert (100) Prozent was möglich ist, was in sein, hm, hm, hm, Macht ist.
David Boder: Nun ja.
Isaac Wolf: Das hat er gemacht für die Juden.
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Und dann sind wir gewesen in Villach die ganze Zeit. Dann hatten die in Villach angefangen liquidieren, weil sie haben nicht gewollt, dass die Juden sollen sein, weil...die Österreicher sind kein Freund von Juden.
David Boder: Was? Österreicher...[unverständlich; beide sprechen]
Isaac Wolf: Ja. Österreicher, ja.
David Boder: Haben was?
Isaac Wolf: Haben gesehen, dass sich die Juden in den Gassen sich befanden. Und man hat geschlagen , sie...
David Boder: Sie sagen die Österreicher haben geschlagen die Juden?
Isaac Wolf: Ja ich bin da gestanden, wie ein Jud ist hin gegangen und hat genommen ein Holz. Das war eine Fabrik...nicht eine Fabrik...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . aber eine Säge, wo man hat gesägt Holz. Bretter...Bretter zu machen diese Barracken für die Juden. Das war im Wald, hm, nicht weit von der Stadt, so drei (3) Kilometer. Sind die Deutschen zu gegangen und haben geschlagen die Juden, weil die Juden wollten Holz da. Und das Holz war für das Lager. Aber er hat...und dann hat er geschlagen den Jud und der Jud ist geblieben. Acht (8) Tage ist er gelegen krank. Und wir haben den Deutschen genommen und man hat in gebringt da rüber ins Lager. Und gesagt zu die Engländer: „Wenn Sie diesen Menschen nicht einsperren, dann werden wir betrachten die Engländer die selben, wie die Deutschen und wir werden, wir haben ja gar nichts zu verlieren, und wir werden machen, ihr sollt uns alle tot schlagen. Und als Rache für diesen Menschen werden wir die Deutschen auch erschlagen. Dann haben sie genommen—der Mr. Katz und hat ihn übergeben zu der englischen Polizei. Was sie haben gemacht, die englische Polizei, weiß ich nicht mit ihm. Aber nach acht (8) Tage haben wir getroffen in der Stadt—denselben Österreicher hat man heraus gelassen.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Und er hat nicht mehr gewohnt in dieser Wohnung, weil er Angst gehabt vor den Juden.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und er hat gewohnt in der Stadt Velden, Österreich Die Engländer haben ihn heraus gelassen auch. Da haben wir gesehen, dass der Engländer entweder...ich weiß nicht, wie ich soll verstehen, damals habe ich mich bemüht das zu verstehen. Die denken einfach sie sollen die Juden schlagen oder was? Und dann haben wir gesehen, wir haben ja gar nichts zu verlieren. Das Essen war sehr schlecht. Wenn der Mr. Katz da gewesen ist, war alles gut. Und dann waren da so viele Leute. Und das Konzentrations...das Lager ist übertragen auf einen anderen Ort. Und man hat gesagt das Lager wird übertragen in einen Wald zwischen Bergen, dass die Juden sind abgeschnitten von der Stadt.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Nun habe ich bemerkt: nach sechs (6) Jahren Krieg und was wir haben mitgemacht, nun wieder herein gehen in ein neues Lager. Und dort waren wir keine Menschen...und warum sollen wir das machen? Und wir haben beschlossen, wir gehen wieder nach Salzburg zu die Amerikaner.
Isaac Wolf: Zu der amerikanischen Seite.
David Boder: So sind Sie gegangen mit Erlaubnis oder ohne Erlaubnis?
Isaac Wolf: Ohne Erlaubnis.
David Boder: Wie viele Menschen sind sie gegangen?
Isaac Wolf: Wir sind gegangen gruppenweise.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Wir sind gegangen—ich habe genommen siebzehn (17) Menschen mit mir.
Isaac Wolf: Mit schwangere Frauen mit Kinder. Wir sind zu Fuß über die Berge.
David Boder: Nun.
Isaac Wolf: Nun wir sind herüber gegangen und haben bekommen [unverständlich]. Dann sind wir herein gegangen und da waren schon Juden, das war ganz gut. Und da hat man uns schon gegeben zu essen und zu trinken. Die Amerikaner haben uns nicht gewollt registrieren, aber man hat doch registriert.
David Boder: Ja?
Isaac Wolf: Und man hat uns gegeben...
David Boder: Was hat man denn gewollt? Zurück schicken?
Isaac Wolf: Zurück schicken...nein! Man wird gefangen von der Grenzstreife und man wird eingesperrt. Die Amerikaner auch...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Sie verstehen...weil wenn man gegangen ist illegal über die Grenzen. Wir haben gesagt: „Was für Grenzen gehen wir rüber? Wir gehen von einem Lager zum Anderen. Das war schlecht, nun haben wir wieder schlecht nach sechs (6) Jahre Krieg...was für Verbrechen haben wir gemacht? Wir sind übrig geblieben so einige Juden“. In Lagern in der österreichischen Zone, wo die Engländer sind gewesen, haben die Juden nicht gewollt sein, das war ärger, genau so...wie bei die Deutschen.
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Ohne Erlaubnis hat man nicht gekonnt gehen. Erst Mal wir haben nichts. Und dann sind wir gekommen nach Salzburg. Von Salzburg sind wir gegangen nach Italien.
David Boder: Nach wohin?
Isaac Wolf: Italien.
David Boder: Italien—legal order illegal?
Isaac Wolf: Illegal.
David Boder: Sprechen Sie lauter.
Isaac Wolf: Illegal sind wir gegangen.
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Und von Italien sind wir herein gekommen hierher. Man hat uns schon gegeben Hilfe. Auch von dem jüdischen Kommittee.
David Boder: Wie können über die Grenze so viele Menschen illegal?
Isaac Wolf: Wir sind gegangen bei Nacht über die Berge. Zwei haben Füße gebrochen, einer hat die Hand gebrochen, ohne...ohne...
David Boder: Gibt es wen, der Sie geführt hat? Oder...
Isaac Wolf: Wir haben gehabt...Einer hat uns geführt.
David Boder: Wer? Ein Italiener?
Isaac Wolf: Nein, das war ein Griechischer.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Wir haben ihm gezahlt etwas Geld und er hat geführt. Einer hat die Uhr von der Hand, Einer hat gehabt einen Ring gehabt, was man halt gehabt hat, hat man ihm gegeben und er hat uns geführt über die Berge.
Isaac Wolf: Und über die Berge hat er uns geführt. Wir sind gekommen nach Italien. Und in Italien sind wir herein gekommen und sind gekommen nach Mailand.
David Boder: Nach Mailand, ja!
Isaac Wolf: In Mailand hat das jüdische Kommittee uns Hilfe gegeben. Man hat uns gegeben in das Lager Cremona.
David Boder: Wo ist das?
Isaac Wolf: Das ist...von Mailand, hm, acht (8) Kilometer, es ist nicht weit.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Isaac Wolf: Man hat uns herein geführt nach Mailand und dort sind wir gewesen in einem Lager.
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Wir sind herein gekommen ins so ein Lager, wie ein Stall, Zement und „Bricken“.
David Boder: Was?
Isaac Wolf: Stein und „Bricken“
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: . . . ohne Holz...
David Boder: Sie meinen unter die Füße?
Isaac Wolf: Ja.
David Boder: Ich meine, der Fußboden von Stein?
Isaac Wolf: Der Boden, ja!
David Boder: . . . war aus Stein.
Isaac Wolf: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Was war das gewesen zuvor?
Isaac Wolf: Ds war gewesen ein...eine Kasern...eine Kaserne von Soldaten war das zuvor.
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Nun, es war offen, ohne Türe, ohne Fenster. So haben wir gewohnt—in einem Zimmer haben wir gewohnt—achtzig Mann. Der ganze...mein ganzer Kibbuz war hier zusammen...,
Isaac Wolf: Und wir sind gewesen dort. Und dort haben wir sehr schwer mit gemacht...kalt,...hungrig.
David Boder: In welchem Monat war das?
Isaac Wolf: Es war...hm...das kann ich Ihnen sagen, zwei Monate zurück war das.
David Boder: Oh, bloß zwei Monate zurück?
Isaac Wolf: Zwei Monate zurück bin ich heraus gekommen...bin ich heraus gekommen von Cremona. Ich war...
David Boder: In...in...
Isaac Wolf: . . . und ich war dort sechs Monate.
David Boder: Aha. Also sind Sie gekommen nach Cremona wann? Ungefähr in welchem Monat? September, Oktober?
Isaac Wolf: Nein, das kann ich Ihnen sagen, das war...
David Boder: Nun.
Isaac Wolf: Im März bin ich gekommen!
David Boder: Oh, März!
Isaac Wolf: Im März, ja, ja, im März bin ich gekommen. Im März bin ich gekommen nach Cremona.
David Boder: Und in Cremona, wie ich bin gekommen, war es noch ein bisserl kalt, Sie verstehen?
Isaac Wolf: Ja.
David Boder: Ja, ja. Also Sie waren sechs (6) Monate in Cremona?
Isaac Wolf: Nein. Das ist schon...es ist jetzt dass ich in Italien...
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: . . . in Italien schon sechs (6) Monate war.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Ja, ich war...
David Boder: Und wann sind Sie weg gegangen von Österreich?
Isaac Wolf: Von Österreich?
David Boder: Sechs (6) oder acht (8) Monate zurück?
Isaac Wolf: Ja, ich bin gewandert...
David Boder: Oh!
Isaac Wolf: . . . von einer Stadt zur anderen. In Innsbruck war ich...von Innsbruck wieder...Sie glauben, es ist nicht so leicht von Österreich...von der amerikanischen Zone auf die französische Zone, weil Innsbruck ist die französische Zone...
David Boder: Aber warum überspringen Sie das? Sagen Sie es mir so...
Isaac Wolf: Ich verstehe.
David Boder: . . . [unverständlich]...doch leicht zu verstehen.
Isaac Wolf: . . . bin ich herüber gegangen von der amerikanischen Zone in die französische Zone.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Von der französischen Zone sind wir schon nach Italien. Und wir sind herüber gekommen und dort...
David Boder: Waren die Franzosen besser?
Isaac Wolf: Die Franzosen waren wunderbar. Sie haben uns gelassen gehen, sie haben nicht gestört uns.
David Boder: Aha, nun?
Isaac Wolf: Und sie haben gehabt, mitgefühlt...sie haben Mitgefühl gehabt mit uns.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Und sie haben verstanden, was die Juden haben mitgemacht. Haben sie erlaubt gehen. Aber wir hatten gar keine Erlaubnis, aber doch, hm,...
David Boder: Waren mit Ihnen Männer und Frauen?
Isaac Wolf: Frauen und Kinder...
David Boder: Alle Möglichen.
Isaac Wolf: . . . sechzehn (16) Jährige waren mit uns.
David Boder: Sie gehen in die Berge alle zusammen, auch sechzehn(16) Jährige...[beide sprechen]
Isaac Wolf: Zusammen, mit eine 16 Jährigen, er war mit uns.
David Boder: Was tut man, wenn man geht? Hat man geredet oder...?
Isaac Wolf: Nein, gar nichts! Wir waren gegangen ganz still. Wir haben als Taschentuch herein gegeben in den Mund...
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: . . . und da muss man nicht bemerken bei der Grenze, dass...
Isaac Wolf: . . . jemand geht.
David Boder: Aha.
Isaac Wolf: Und meine Frau war eine schwangere Frau.
David Boder: Wann haben Sie sich verheiratet?
Isaac Wolf: Ich hab mich verheiratet, hm,eh...ein Jahr bin ich verheiratet. In Budapest.
David Boder: In Budapest haben Sie geheiratet?
Isaac Wolf: In Budapest...amtlich...
David Boder: Nach dem Krieg?
Isaac Wolf: Ja.
David Boder: Haben Sie Ihre Frau vorher gekannt?
Isaac Wolf: Nein, ich habe sie in der Zeit von der russischen Armee hab ich...schon gekannt.
David Boder: Und dann...wie lange haben Sie sie haben sie geheirat?
Isaac Wolf: Oh, drei Monate.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Ich war mit der russischen Armee dort in Budapest...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . dort habe ich sie gekannt.
David Boder: Ist Ihre Frau eine Rumänin?
Isaac Wolf: Eine Rumänin...ungarisch.
David Boder: Ungarisch.
Isaac Wolf: Und ich bin lange genug mit meiner Frau und ich selbst ohne [unverständlich] was gekommen, wir haben gar nichts mitgenommen. Und es war kalt, Schnee war auf dem Berg.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Das sind Steinberg.
Isaac Wolf: Und trotzdem sind wir gegangen und wir haben ausgezogen diese...hm...
David Boder: Kleider.
Isaac Wolf: . . . Kleider, denn es war sehr heiß und man hat sich [unverständlich] die Füß. Und dann sind wir herein nach Italien. Und in Italien sind wir dann nach Cremona und in Cremona sind wir gewesen drei Monat und dann sind wir gegangen...
David Boder: Wieder zu Fuß oder sind Sie gefahren?
Isaac Wolf: Wir haben Angst gehabt zu fahren auch, weil auf der Bahn hat man auch Polizei gesehen und hat gefragt. Und dann haben wir nicht gekonnt die italienische Sprache.
David Boder: Ja?
Isaac Wolf: Bis wir sind so herein gekommen so sechzig (60) oder achtzig (80) Kilometer von der Grenze, dort haben wir dann genommen die Bahn.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und dann...sind wir, nach Verona sind wir gekommen.
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Und in Verona haben wir uns rauf gesetzt auf die Bahn und wir sind gefahren bis Mailand.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Von Mailand, man hat uns geschickt nach Cremona. So sind wir gewesen in Cremona. Und in Cremona da haben wir es gehabt sehr schlecht auch, weil mit dem Essen war es sehr schlecht.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Dieser UNRRA Direktor hat nicht gefühlt so mit Juden, so in...
David Boder: War er Jude oder...
Isaac Wolf: Nein, er war...ein Offizier, ein englischer Offizier. Und dort war noch nicht die UNRRA, dort hat noch die englische Regierung hat noch gegeben zu essen,...die Polizei.
David Boder: Ja?
Isaac Wolf: Und dann hatten sie...dann haben wir so gebeten [unverständlich] sie sollen uns doch herein geben in einen Kibbuz, weil in einem Kibbuz bekommt man vielleicht etwas mehr. Wenn wir sind in einem Kibbuz und sagen wir einmal wir wollen fahren nach Eretz. So hat man uns genommen herein in Tradate und in Tradate arbeiten wir und wir lernen sich Schuster und Schneider und Friseur.
David Boder: Wer unterrichtet hier? Sie haben doch keine ORT Schule hier?
Isaac Wolf: Nein, wir haben...Einer dem Anderen lernt. Wir haben, zum Beispiel, sagen wir drei (3) Schuster, so ein Junger dann mit denen...soll lernen.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Schneider auch so, Sie verstehen
David Boder: Hm. Man lernt sich Einer vom Anderen.
Isaac Wolf: Einer vom Anderen. Spezielle Schule haben wir nicht. Und wenn ich in Österreich bin ich gewesen, dort hab ich...dieser Herr Katz, der hat gelernt in meiner Zeit jetzt—sechzig (60) jüdische Chauffeure hat er heraus. Er hat produziert...
David Boder: Ausgelernt?
Isaac Wolf: Ausgelernt. Und er hat gesagt drei (3) [unverständlich] Arbeiter sollen sein, Sie verstehen?
David Boder: Hm, ja.
Isaac Wolf: Es ist möglich, man kann auslernen zwanzig Andere. Man hat es so gelernt. Und da...hier—ich weiß nicht warum, man hat nicht gelernt, man hat nicht die Möglichkeit...
David Boder: Hier in Tradate?
Isaac Wolf: Ja. Sie haben ja gesehen, das wir kein Wasser haben gehabt so eine Zeitlang. Jetzt haben wir Wasser gehabt, aber sehr wenig...
David Boder: Sie haben jetzt hier UNRRA oder Joint?
Isaac Wolf: Hier ist die UNRRA mit Joint zusammen.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und...
David Boder: Nun, sagen Sie mir dies. Wenn Sie sind hier her gekommen, waren schon Menschen hier in Tradate?
Isaac Wolf: Ja.
David Boder: Nun, erzählen Sie mir ein bissel. Wir Amerikaner oder in Amerika wir wissen gar nichts über diese Kibbuzim. Wie lebt man es hier, wie ist das Ganze organisiert?
Isaac Wolf: Die Organisation ist so. Wir bekommen von der UNRRA drei tausend (3000) Lire ein Monat.
David Boder: Ja, das ist drei...das ist was? Hundert (100) Lire pro Tag.
Isaac Wolf: Hundert Lire am Tag.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Mit diesen brauchen wir leben.
David Boder: Wem gibt man das Geld und wer versorgt das Gel?
Isaac Wolf: Das Geld bringt...die UNRRA schickt es herein für uns auf die Bank.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und da haben wir ein Kommittee.
Isaac Wolf: Und das Kommittee sorgt für dieses was wir brauchen.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Das ist so...für Lebensmittel kann man nicht erlauben mehr auszugeben wie achtzig (80) Lire...
David Boder: Am Tag?
Isaac Wolf: Am Tag.
David Boder: Was tut man mit dem Anderen?
Isaac Wolf: Das Andere ist so. Es gibt wenn einer krank ist, es gibt, wenn einer hat keine Schuhe, weil wir haben nämlich keine Schuhe. Viele haben keine Schuhe [unverständlich].
David Boder: Nun und wenn schwangere Frauen haben Kinder, wer sorgt dafür?
Isaac Wolf: Das gibt man ins Spital herein
David Boder: Aha, wer zahlt dafür?
Isaac Wolf: Das Spital. Die UNRRA gibt nicht mehr. Der Doktor hat mir gesagt diese Woche: „Wenn von Euch kommt Kranke zu mir, ich nehm sie sehr gern an. Aber wir haben ja gar nichts, denn die UNRRA zahlt nur für das Zimmer.“
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Aber für die Ärzte oder für...für...zahlt nicht. Für Zimmer und Lebensmittel für diese paar Tage und mehr bekommen sie gar nicht.
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Da hab ich ihm geantwortet: „Was kann ich Ihnen machen? Ich hab kein Geld, mit dem ich sie belohne“. Aber dann haben wir etwas bekommen, das menschliche Gefühl, verstehen Sie.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Dann, wenn es möglich ist, wir geben für die Schwestern, dass sie behandeln gut. Es sind jetzt dort zwei (2) schwangere Frauen und eine Frau, die was gehabt einen Operation von Blinddarm.
David Boder: In welchem Spital war das?
Isaac Wolf: Hier in Tradate. Die Bedingunge...
David Boder: Welches Spital ist das?
Isaac Wolf: Die Be...das ist in unserer Stadt...ein...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . das ist klein...und privat auch. Aber dieser Professor ist ein sehr anständiger Mensch. Er ist...er hat Mitgefühl mit Juden, Sie verstehen?
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Isaac Wolf: Und er gibt sie herein. Und weiter können wir da nicht mithelfen, weil wir haben ja selbst gar nichts. Diese achtzig (8) Lire oder neunzig (90), wenn wir erlauben sich, muss man sich ausgeben andere...hm,...
David Boder: Dinge?
Isaac Wolf: Dinge. Zum Beispiel, sagen wir ins Kino zu gehen oder irgend etwas Anderes.
David Boder: Was heißt, wenn Eine ins Kino gehen will, kriegt er Geld von ihnen?
Isaac Wolf: Von unseren...von unsere hundert (100) Lire was wir bekommen. Von den drei tausend (3000) Lire pro Person, Sie verstehen?
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Wir selbst...unsere Person, Sie verstehen...wenn wir wollen gehen ins Kino, müssen wir selbst organisieren, dann soll es billiger kosten.
David Boder: Aha.
Isaac Wolf: Sie verstehen?
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: So können wir auch nicht...einmal in zwei Wochen oder einmal in der Woche.
David Boder: Aber warum können Sie kein Kino hierher bekommen?
Isaac Wolf: Weil wir bekommen es nicht, ich weiß nicht warum. Das ist, wir bekommen es nicht und dann kann man es nicht bekommen.
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Ich weiß nicht warum. In Österreich da hat es Mr. Katz bekommen da. Und da weiß ich nicht warum.
David Boder: Nun und wie lange, denken Sie, wir man hier herum sitzen?
Isaac Wolf: Das ist nicht abhängig von uns. Wir können heute gehen und wenn sie uns lassen, gehen wir zu Fuß auch, weil wir...
David Boder: Was heißt „wenn sie uns lassen?“
Isaac Wolf: Nun Sie wissen was wir sind...
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Weil wir werden gestört von die Engländer, von, von den Italieners...
David Boder: Wohin werden sie gehen?
Isaac Wolf: . . . die lassen uns nicht raus. Hm, überhaupt wir wollen nach Palästina. Wir haben kein anderes zu Hause. Wo können wir hingehen? Weil, wer kann uns garantieren, dann in einem Jahr oder in einem halben Jahr nicht wieder das Selbe nicht vorkommt? So wie da hier...war ein Russischer...ein Ukrainer waren da hier auch in einem Konzentrationslager. Vielleicht haben Sie gehört?
David Boder: Nein.
Isaac Wolf: Bei Radzimilov. Sie haben nicht gehört davon?
David Boder: Nein, nein.
Isaac Wolf: Da war ein Lager und es waren Juden und Ukrainer.
David Boder: In Italien?
Isaac Wolf: In Italien. Haben sie angefangen und man hat vier (4) Juden tot geschlagen. Zwei (2) hat man am Ort getötet und zwei (2) sind im Spital gestorben. Kranke, das heißt, sie blieben tot und zwei waren noch plessiert...
David Boder: Verwundet?
Isaac Wolf: Verwundet.
David Boder: Wie? Was hat da passiert? Was für ein Lager war das?
Isaac Wolf: Die Ukrainer. Das waren Ukrainer, diese was haben nicht wollen, hm,...
David Boder: Nach Hause?
Isaac Wolf: . . . nach Hause, weil sie haben Angst, weil sie haben Juden geschlagen, tot geschlagen, weil sie haben geraubt die Juden. Sie halten sich da hier unter der englischen Macht. Und die Engländer schicken sie nicht nach Haus.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Und die Russischen haben schon vielmals gefordert, sie sollen heim gehen, aber die Engländer schicken sie nicht nach Haus.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und sie sind frei und sie haben noch viel mehr Möglichkeiten,viel mehr wie die Juden. Weil die Juden, wenn sie wollen weg fahren, lassen sie die Juden nicht. Sie wissen wie es mit den Juden ist. Und sie gehen, sie fragen nicht. Und auf einmal sehen sie...sie sagen: „Was da hier sind auch Juden.“ Und sie sind herein gekommen in das jüdische Lager und man hat die Juden geschlagen. Das war in Radzimirov.
David Boder: Und die Engländer?
Isaac Wolf: Und die englische Polizei kam auch herein, das...was sie sollen helfen etwas den Juden, sie sollen nicht schlagen. Haben sie noch die Juden arretiert und die Ukrainer haben sie weg gefahren in Autos...damit sich die Juden sollen nicht revanchieren für die vier Toten.
David Boder: Die Ukrainer haben sie weg genommen?
Isaac Wolf: Haben sie weg genommen von hier.
David Boder: Aha.
Isaac Wolf: Und, hm, die italienische Polizei haben sich herein gemischt und die Engländer...und...bis zu dem heutigen Tage...Da haben wir gesehen, dass es kann nicht möglich sein, dass sie Juden sollen nicht zusammen mit die Ukrainer. Der Joint hat es gesehen, der amerikanische Joint hat sich herein geleitet, Sie verstehen?
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und man hat gemacht die Hachsharah Punkte. Die UNRRA hat anfangs nicht gewollt erlauben Hachsharah, aber dann hat man gemacht Hachsharah, dass die Juden sollen sein gesondert von den...
David Boder: Was heißt Hachsharah?
Isaac Wolf: Nun das ist ein Arbeitsort, wo jüdische Halutzim lernen zu arbeiten.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Wir haben ja hier ein Stückerl Feld auch.
Isaac Wolf: Das zeigt Einer dem Anderen, er soll für sich lernen, wie man Grund arbeit...
David Boder: Sagen Sei mir, warum haben Sie jeden Tag zwei Mal Appell, gleich wie im Konzentrationslager?
Isaac Wolf: Nein, wir haben Appell darum, weil wir sagen uns der Arbeit.
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Der Arbeit...wir sagen sich an einen Tag auf den Anderen, was wir so machen, wenn es gemacht...
David Boder: Kann man das nicht tun im Speisesaal?
Isaac Wolf: Nein, das ist nicht...wir haben nicht so einen großen Speisesaal für alle Leute, die wir hier haben. Sie sehen, wie das so mit dem Essen da ist. Mit dem Essen die eine Reihe essen, dann geht die Andere.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Uns so das dauert beim Essen von der einen Reihe zur Anderen eine halbe Stunde bis alles gewaschen ab das Geschirr und alles.
David Boder: Es dauert Zeit von einer...
Isaac Wolf: Ja, selbstverständlich.
David Boder: Wieviel Leute sind jetzt hier alles zusammen?
Isaac Wolf: Nun, wir sind jetzt hier sechs oder sieben hundert (600 oder 700) Leute.
David Boder: Sechs, sieben hundert (6, 700) Leute?
Isaac Wolf: Ja,ungefähr sieben hundert Leute.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Und, hm, darum machen wir Appell zwei (2) Mal am Tag. Was wir zu machen haben und Disziplin auch.
David Boder: Und wenn es regnet wie werden Sie haben Appell? Wo werden Sei den Appell halten wenn es regnet?
Isaac Wolf: Nun, es regnet...ja nicht den ganzen Tag. Wenn es regnet, nach einer halben Stunden, nach einer Stunde ist es frei...
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Dann gehen wir heraus und wir...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . geben Instruktionen. Und wenn nicht, dann sagen wir...es gibt viele Kibbuzim hier. Das ist zum Beispiel, ein Kibbuz sagen wir Zasnia, noch ein Kibbuz hier sagen wir Partisana und Verschiedene. Es gibt natürlich...[unverständlich; beide sprechen]
David Boder: Warum heißt Partisana der Kibbuz?
Isaac Wolf: Das ist...diese waren Partisanen, von der Armee...von der österreichi...von der russischen und, hm, von die polnische, alles Juden...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . was waren in die Wälder.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Sie haben angefangen mit den Partisanen und jetzt sind sie befreit von der polnischen Armee. Und sie haben Niemanden zu Hause. Was waren in vielen Fällen Polen, die sind weg gelaufen, weil die Polen die Juden angegriffen haben die Juden. Sie haben gesagt, sie wollen nicht haben in Polen keine Juden.
Isaac Wolf: Sie wollen haben ein rein polnisches Land.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und die russische Regierung hat sich herein gemischt und die russische Polizei auch. Nun Sie wissen mit den Russen, es ist auch nicht hundert (100) Prozent demokratisch auch. Also, Viele sind von der Ukraine, Ukrainer und die haben die Juden auch nicht lieb! Es gab viele Fälle in Krakau...
David Boder: Was ist das?
Isaac Wolf: Krakau, wo sind geschlagen worden die Juden auch in den Gassen. Einer ist zu einem Juden ins Geschäft gekommen und hat ihn tot geschlagen und hat ihm alles weg genommen. Und sie haben gesagt, sie brauchen das Geld nicht für sich, sondern die polnische Organisation soll...gegen die Juden. Und deswegen haben sie keinen Platz, wohin sie kommen, die Juden. Sie waren in der Slowakei...
David Boder: Was für eine polnische Organisation ist gegen die Juden, die sie...
Isaac Wolf: Die polnische, hm, hm,...
David Boder: Organisation.
Isaac Wolf: . . . die Nationalisten.
David Boder: Oh, die Nationalisten.
Isaac Wolf: Nationalisten.
David Boder: Die waren mit der Londoner Regierung?
Isaac Wolf: Ja, ja, die so helfen mit, Sie verstehen? Und darum, wohin ein Jud geht, da hat er hat kein Ort. Sollte er sagen, der Juden, ich will mich da hin setzen, Sie verstehen...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . er kann sich, aber in drei (3) Tagen bekommt er einen Brief. ‚Wenn er verlasst nicht den Ort, dann wir er tot geschlagen. Und...’
David Boder: Wo passiert das? Wo passiert das?
Isaac Wolf: In Polen, in vielen Dörfern, ich hab gesprochen mit...
David Boder: Von wem bekommt er den Brief?
Isaac Wolf: . . . von Freunden...erhalten...[unverständlich; Lärm im Tape]
David Boder: Nein, ich meine von wem der Jude bekommt den Brief?
Isaac Wolf: Von die Ukrainer, von die Polaken.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Sie verstehen.
David Boder: Nun? Was ist in dem Brief?
Isaac Wolf: Ein Brief, dass...wenn er nicht verlasst das Dorf bis zu einem bestimmten Tage, dann wird er tot geschlagen. Und das waren solche Fälle, wo man geglaubt hat, das ist nur so geschrieben—bis man hat sich überzeugt, war das wirklich. Man ist hereingekommen in der Nacht und hat ihn tot geschlagen.
David Boder: Haben Sie solche Briefe gesehen?
Isaac Wolf: Gesehen und selbst hab ich einen Kollegen, was er hat gebittet nach Amerika was sollen seine Freund sein, dass...
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: . . . sie sollen ihn aufnehmen, weil er ist geblieben Einer von der ganzen Familie und sie sollen ihn herauf nehmen, weil er so schafft, dass er hat sich gerettet das Leben;...nach sechs Jahre Krieg soll er ermordet werden von die, hm,...(6)
David Boder: Polen.
Isaac Wolf: . . . von die Polen, von die Ukrainer. Und er ist gekommen nach Italien und jetzt wartet er. Vielleicht bekommt er Papiere. Er selbst, er hat bekommen diesen Brief auch. Er befindet sich jetzt im Lager Cremona.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Sie verstehen?
David Boder: Und was für ein Lager ist in Cremona.
Isaac Wolf: In Cremona, das ist ein...jetzt ist es ein UNRRA Lager.
David Boder: Nun auch vom Kibbuzim?
Isaac Wolf: Dort...dort sind die meisten, die vielen Menschen, das warten...was warten auf Papiere nach Brasilien, etzetera. Das war...ich habe selbst gestellt eine Frage, warum diese Menschen, was wollen fahren nach Eretz , lasst man liegen so im Kibbuz und gibt keine Hilfe.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Sie verstehen und ich hab das auch gefordert, weil wir wollen fahren nach Eretz und wir wollen arbeiten. Warum...ist, hm,...die Zeit von dem Krieg haben wir geändert. Man hat immer sagen, dass ein Jud ist faul zu der Arbeit. Aber das war ein Irrtum, das zu sagen. Heutige Juden...die Jugend was geblieben ist, gibt es keine schreckliche Arbeit, was das sollen sein keine Arbeit. Hier sind wir arbeitslos.
David Boder: Warum arbeitet man nicht in Italien?
Isaac Wolf: Ich will Ihnen sagen, die italienischen Arbeiter selbst, die Einheimischen haben keine Arbeit. Sie sind hier arbeitslos.
David Boder: Ist hier Arbeitslosigkeit in Italien?
Isaac Wolf: In Italien auch, weil sie keine Fabriken haben.
David Boder: Aha.
Isaac Wolf: Und der Arbeiter, was arbeitet, kann nicht genug [unverständlich] für Essen auch. Ich—mit meinem Kibbuz, zum Beispiel,...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . möchte gerne gehen zur Arbeit jeden Tag, dass ich so kann das Leben verbessern auch. Wie ich war in Cremona, hab ich gesehen, dass ich...wir kann nicht existieren, weil dort gibt es nur das Essen—nur einmal am Tag Brot hat man gegeben. Hab ich selbst genommen...ich wolle meinen Kibbuz erhalten in...
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: . . . hab ich gemacht selbst ein Theaterstück.
David Boder: Ja?
Isaac Wolf: Und ich habe gespielt Theater. Ich habe das Theaterstück hab ich den Namen gegeben: „Und ich Eretz hab ich gefunden mein Glück.“
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Und ich habe das Spiel dort gemacht drei (3) Mal und ich habe ein paar tausend (1000) Lire gemacht.
David Boder: Von wem?
Isaac Wolf: Von diese Menschen was Geld haben gehabt.
David Boder: Im Lager?
Isaac Wolf: Von Milano sind gekommen.
David Boder: Was?
Isaac Wolf: Ich hab eingeladen. Von Milano sind gekommen...von Mailand...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . sind gekommen Menschen. Es waren Menschen, die bekommen Geld von die, hm,...von Amerika, sie verstehen!
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Ich habe gemacht so...für die Ausgaben, was wir haben.
David Boder: Wie weit ist Cremona von Milano?
Isaac Wolf: Von Cremona nach Milano, das ist, hm, ich glaube so achtzig (80) Kilometer.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Ich glaube drei (3) Stunden Fahrt mit Bahn.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und dann habe ich gemacht...gespielt ein Theaterstück selbst. Verfasst von dem Ableben von die Juden von Anfang des Krieg bis zum Ende Krieg.
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Und es war ein sehr schöner Erfolg für mich. Man hat über mich in der Zeitung geschrieben, ich habe das bis heute.
David Boder: Ich welcher Zeitung? Hier in...
Isaac Wolf: In der Jüdischen...in Baderach...
David Boder: In die...in Milan?
Isaac Wolf: In Milan. Ich habe da...ich habe bis zur heutigen Zeit...ich hab die Zeitung, die habe ich noch mit meinem Namen.
David Boder: Wo haben Sie gelernt Theater spielen?
Isaac Wolf: Hm,...wenn ich war noch zu Hause, hab ich noch gespielt mit den Jugendlichen selbst, so für sich.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und ich hab...und es waren das Advokaten eingeladen von Milan und die waren...und Dr. Bernstein von Rom war, aber Professor Bernstein.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Und er hat auch anerkennt, dass es sehr gut zusammen gestellt und ich hab das gespielt und mit dem habe ich meinen Kibbuz ernährt. Das was ich nicht gehabt habe die Möglichkeit zu geben vom Lager...das Essen,...hab ich so gemacht, dass sie so haben zum Frühstück etwas mehr geben und Nachtmal ein bisschen mehr, Sie verstehen.
David Boder: Aha.
Isaac Wolf: Und ich hab gemacht darum, dass ich so kann die Menschen aufhalten, dass sie nicht hungrig werden.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie...ich möchte Sie diese Frage fragen.
Isaac Wolf: Bitte.
David Boder: Ich habe heute morgen gesehen, dass Sie haben in einer Abteilung Männer und Frauen zusammen. Verheiratete Paare schlafen in dem selben Zimmer. Wie...hm, wirkt das auf die Moral von Menschen ?
Isaac Wolf: Nun, ich will Ihnen sagen, das ist...das ist...das Wirkliche—das nicht moralisch, aber wir haben ja keinen Raum...
David Boder: Nein, nein, ich sag nicht, es ist nicht moralisch...[unverständlich; beide sprechen]...
Isaac Wolf: Nicht, das ist es nicht—wir haben keinen Ausweg.
David Boder: . . . ich sage es nur aus dem Gefühl...
Isaac Wolf: Nein, das ist es nicht...es ist sehr schlecht...,
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Na, wir haben ja keinen Ausweg!
David Boder: Warum nicht
Isaac Wolf: Weil wir haben ja nicht so viel Platz.
David Boder: Na, kann man nicht alle Frauen haben in einem Ende...[unverständlich]...
Isaac Wolf: Nun, gut, ich will Ihnen sagen, wenn man kann nicht mehr mit diesem Mann...für kurze Zeit kann man ins andere [unverständlich] gehen und die Frau...
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: . . . und wenn es ist für eine lange Zeit...wir wissen nicht wie lange wir hier müssen hier sein
David Boder: Oh!
Isaac Wolf: Da kann man da nicht nehmen eine Frau gesondert und ein Mann gesondert. Sie verstehen. Wenn...
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie...
Isaac Wolf: Ja.
David Boder: Wie verhalten sie sich? Ich will Sie eine ganz offene Frage fragen? Wenn Mann mit der Frau...sie leben, sie haben Verhältnis. Hören müssen doch die anderen Menschen?
Isaac Wolf: Nun ich will Ihnen sagen, das ist,...das ist...
David Boder: Ich frage...[unverständlich; beide sprechen]
Isaac Wolf: Nun, ja, ja, ja...
David Boder: . . . eine psychologische Frage.
Isaac Wolf: Das ist in Ordnung, ich sage Ihnen die Wahrheit. Ich kann Ihnen selbst über die Wahrheit von mir sagen.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Es war auch...jetzt habe ich ein kleines Kind und da habe ich ein besonderes Zimmer, aber bis jetzt habe ich auch gewohnt mit einer schwangeren Frau. Aber auch...ich kann Ihnen nur sagen, dass wir haben gewohnt wie solche Fremde...
David Boder: Was meinen Sie „wie Fremde“?
Isaac Wolf: Nun besonders...weil ein Bett neben dem Anderen und man hat sich geniert vor einander. Sie verstehen, das ist nicht moralisch, wenn man Verhältnisse hat zwischen fremde Leut. Sie verstehen. Und es war sehr...selbstverständlich wie ein Kollege hat mir gesagt: „Ich hab eine Frau“, sagt er „aber nur auf einem Bild.“
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: „Ich kann nicht“, hat er gesagt „mit meiner Frau...“
David Boder: Hm, Sie meinen, er hat mit seiner Frau gelebt?
Isaac Wolf: Selbstverständlich, das ist nicht eine Stelle, hm, hm, wo Andere schlafen. Weil wir haben ja gewohnt ein Bett neben dem Anderen.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und man hat sich nicht...man ist ja ein Mensch.
Isaac Wolf: Man kann es nicht erlauben, dass ein Mensch soll dem Anderen, hm,...verstehen Sie,...schauen was...schauen was da kommt vor. Darum hat man so einen Namen gehabt, man hat gesagt zu seiner Frau: „ich habe ein Frau, aber kein Verhältnis!“
David Boder: Meinen Sie, Sie halten sich zurück?
Isaac Wolf: Selbstverständlich!
David Boder: Nicht dass Sie sich gewöhnt haben, dass eine...
Isaac Wolf: Nein, nein, das nicht.
David Boder: Das nicht.
Isaac Wolf: Das nicht.
David Boder: Sie schlafen bloß zusammen und nicht mehr?
Isaac Wolf: Und nicht mehr, leider, weil ich kann nicht erlauben, dass [unverständliches Flüstern].
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Sehr schrecklich das Leben, aber was kann man machen?
David Boder: Und die UNRRA weiß das? Und die Anderen wissen es auch?
Isaac Wolf: Ich werde es Ihnen sagen. Die UNRRA kommen, in zehn (10) Minuten, die schauen nur an, dass es rein soll sein. Und wenn sie wirklich sollen...ich hab da gehabt...sie sind herein gekommen diese Woche. Und haben angeschaut, dass wir haben kein Wasser, keine Toiletten, denn die Toiletten sind alle verstopft.
David Boder: Ja?
Isaac Wolf: Da hab ich gesagt: „Vielleicht wollen Sie, dass wir sollen alle krank werden aus Malaria oder Typhus oder alles.“ Sie sollen etwas Hilfe uns geben, dass wir sollen Wasser haben. Ich habe bezahlt einmal elf tausend (11000) Lire, einmal dreizehn tausend (13000) Lire und das Wasser war nur zwei (2) oder (3) Tage. Der Motor ist kaputt und ich kann das nicht zahlen—dreizehn tausend (13000) Lire von den hundert (100) Lire, was ich bekomm. Man kommt aus ein paar Tage, dann machen wir einen Hungerstreik oder 50% geben zuerst.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Sie verstehen?
David Boder: Nun?
Isaac Wolf: Und ich bin herein gefahren zu Joint. Ich hab zu Joint diese, hm, diese vorgestellt...diese, hm...
David Boder: Situation?
Isaac Wolf: Nun ja, man hat mir versprochen, wenn Mr. Weitz ist hier, er ist krank und, hm, im Spital.
David Boder: Mr. Weitz.
Isaac Wolf: Mr. Weitz.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Ja. Er ist ein sehr—ich kann Ihnen sagen—ein sehr freundlicher Mensch.
Isaac Wolf: Und er hat sich bemüht, vom Spital, glaube ich, weil sie haben gesagt, sie werden anfragen im Spital.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und er hat gesagt, man soll das machen und gestern hat man gebracht...
David Boder: Ja, ich habe gesehen die Pumpe.
Isaac Wolf: Ja. Man hat gebracht die Pumpe und man hat gebracht dies und das. Und dann diese, die sich haben bemüht vom Joint, dem amerikanischen Joint, haben wir Wasser heute, Und heute werden wir machen wieder ein Bad, weil wir haben zwei (2) Woche kein Wasser nicht gehabt und man hat kein Bad nicht gekannt.
David Boder: Also was hat man gehabt zum Waschen, wie hat man das Wasser bekommen?
Isaac Wolf: Wir haben...mit einem Wagen haben wir bringen müssen das Wasser da her.
David Boder: Hm. Und jetzt?
Isaac Wolf: Und jetzt haben wir Wäsch zu waschen, sich selbst auch, wenn man darf.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Es war schrecklich. Mit Holz es war auch hier schrecklich.
David Boder: Ja? Wieso?
Isaac Wolf: Das Holz geht von dieser Unterstützung, was wir bekommen—diese hundert (100) Lire, wird herunter genommen für Holz. Ein Meter Holz, hundert Kilo kostet drei hundert (300) Lire.
David Boder: Hm. Im Winter, was wird man dann tun?
Isaac Wolf: Das weiß ich nicht. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen die Lage, wenn es kommen da hier Winter.
David Boder: Und die Betten und die Decken, hat man die Ihnen gegeben?
Isaac Wolf: Das war hier. Das ist schon gekommen von Joint, von UNRRA. Das war schon hier.
David Boder: Ja, aber man gibt Ihnen keine Laken oder Handtücher?
Isaac Wolf: Das haben wir nicht. Keine Handtücher. Für Seife muss ich laufen ein paar Mal bis ich kann bekommen. Das haben wir auch nicht genug, die Seife und mit Essen, das sehen Sie ja.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mir, gibt es nicht Manche, die bekommen von Amerika was geschickt?
Isaac Wolf: Es gibt welche Leute, nicht im Kibbuz.
David Boder: Sie kriegen was?
Isaac Wolf: Diese was bekommen von Amerika, zum Beispiel, die sitzen im Lager dort und legen sich zu. Aber im Kibbuz überhaupt das sehr genau...hier...es gibt welche Kollegen, die was bekommen, zwei (2) Dollar so geschickt im Brief so. So gibt er das herein in den Kibbuz.
David Boder: Er gibt es herein in den Kibbuz?
Isaac Wolf: Ja, ja. Ich selbst habe gehabt einen Kollegen...[unverständlich; beide sprechen]
David Boder: Sie meinen er kann kein Geld haben?
Isaac Wolf: Nein. Wir haben kein Geld. Ich will Ihnen sagen, diese Leute, die sind in einem Kibbuz, sie sagen, dass ein andere Kollege sind das selbe was er ist selbst—er sieht keinen Unterschied. Ich habe einen Kollegen, der hat bekommen viele Dollar in einem Brief.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Und ein Paket. Das hat er hereingebracht, da hat er bekommen Schokolade. Er hat es herein gebracht für die Kinder und hat gesagt, wir sollen es verteilen.
David Boder: Was?
Isaac Wolf: Ja und wir, so...
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Wir leben so.
David Boder: Und so ein Kibbuz ist wirklich...wirklich...eine...sozusagen eine kommunistische Organisation?
Isaac Wolf: Nein!
David Boder: Nein, ich meine in der Wirtschaft. Alle haben alles zusammen.
Isaac Wolf: Alle haben alles zusammen. Ich sage Ihnen...[unverständlich; beide sprechen]
David Boder: Ich meine das nicht politisch.
Isaac Wolf: Ja, nicht politisch [lacht etwas], das ist ja selbstverständlich.
David Boder: Sagen wir wie eine Kooperative
Isaac Wolf: Oh ja. Wir haben, sagen wir, religiöse Leute hier. Wir haben eine Koscher Küche auch.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Sie verstehen?
Isaac Wolf: Und wir haben eine allgemeine Küche. Wenn wir wollten alle essen Koscher, so wie man sagt, kann man nicht existieren, weil ein Kilo Fleisch kostet drei hundert (300) Lire, drei hundert fünfzig (350) Lire.
David Boder: Ein Kilo Koscher Fleisch?
Isaac Wolf: Nein, das Gewöhnliche...Rind.
David Boder: Ja.
Isaac Wolf: Wenn wir haben bekommen die drei tausend Lire, war ein Kilo Fleisch...
Isaac Wolf: . . . war zwei hundert fünfzig (250). Und jetzt kostet es drei hundert fünfzig (350). Und wir bekommen immer die drei tausend Lire genau. Erhöhung bekommen wir nicht.
David Boder: Hm.
Isaac Wolf: Und wir haben auch die Koscher Küche genau das Selbe. Jeder lebt hier kollektiv, weil wenn nicht kollektiv, dann kann man nicht existieren.
David Boder: Nun, Mr. Wolf, es war alles sehr interessant und sehr wichtig. Ich denke, Sie haben mir da eine gute Geschichte erzählt.
Isaac Wolf: Ich habe Ihnen die Wahrheit gesagt.
David Boder: Nun, ja, ich sage eben, sie haben mir einen guten Report gegeben und so Manches ist klar geworden und Manches wird klarer werden, wenn die Leute dieses Dokument studieren werden. Ich danke Ihnen sehr.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool number 101 the second spool of Mr. Isaac Wolf, who is an officer at one of the Kibutzes at the Camp Tradate between Como and Milan. An Illinois Institute of Technology Wire Recording, September the 1st, 1946.